[Music]
Okay. Um, hey everybody. Thank you so
much for coming. Uh, really appreciate
you being here. Um, this this is a great
show. I love this show. Um, I was here
last year as an attendee. Um, spoke in
New York uh at the the New York Summit
in February and I'm I'm really thrilled
to be back. Um, so this is very much a
showand tell. I I I said this in the
Slack channel, so anybody's not in the
Slack channel, feel free to join it.
There's a couple links in there that
might be helpful to you. Um, it is
workshop Langraph MCP agents if anybody
needs that. Um, but fundamentally, uh,
I'm I'm just here to walk through some
some really interesting work, um, that
my team's been doing around, um,
building agent workflows for, uh, a
healthcare use case. Um, and, uh, this
is this is very much like the way we did
it. Um, I'll get into some details about
that. It's not the only way to do it.
Um, and I'm hopeful that somebody in
this audience might look at this and be
like, "That's dumb. You should do that
better." And, you know, please raise
your hand and tell me. Um, but, uh, but
it's been really fun to build. I'm
really really happy with the results.
And, uh, really excited to show you guys
um, what it's all about. Um, okay. So, I
will go into presentation mode.
All right. Here we go. Okay. Uh first
just a very quick couple things about
Stride. Um that's me if anybody needs my
LinkedIn but um there's a couple other
places you can find that. Um we are a
custom software consultancy. Um so what
that means in practice is uh whatever
you need we'll build it. We have been
doing a whole lot of AI stuff. Um this
kind of falls into a few specific
buckets. Um we use a lot of AI for code
generation. Um we we have a couple of
both products and services we've built
to do things like uh unit test creation
and and maintenance. We've done a bunch
of stuff around uh modernization of of
super old dumb code bases. Um you know
things like uh you know early 2000s
era.net is one of the things we
specialize in. Um but what I'm going to
show you today is really uh what we do
around agent workflows. So the the idea
with you know this agent workflow stuff
is really just that you know it's
something that could be done with
traditional software and and this thing
I'm going to show you was done with
traditional software in its first run.
Um, but we have rebuilt it with an LLM
at the core to make it more flexible,
more capable, and you know, ultimately,
um, just a lot cooler. Um, so, uh,
really excited to show you guys more
about that. So, I'm going to start with
a little bit of grounding. Um, I'm going
to do a case study, um, which is very
brief, but I'll give you a sense of kind
of the problem we were trying to solve
and and and how well I think we solved
it. Um, and then we'll go as as deep as
we all want to go in terms of of how it
works. Um, let me ask this up front. If
you have questions, please raise your
hand. I will try to notice and I'll try
to get to you. Um, there are some mics
we could pass around. Um, but it
probably is better for you just to shout
it out and then I'll repeat it um into
into my mic. Um, and and fundamentally
like I have no idea if this is two hours
worth of material. It probably is, but
you know, please uh keep me honest. Um,
I'll talk about anything that is
relevant to this that you guys want to
talk about. So, um, the client here uh
is Aila. So, Aila Science is uh a
women's health um sort of institution
which is trying to help with uh the
treatment of early pregnancy loss um
otherwise usually known as miscarriage.
Um what what this is though is
specifically a treatment where what
happens is that you know you experience
the event you end up at the hospital or
at a clinic. They send you home with
medicine, right? The medicine is
something that then you have to
administer yourself um at both a very
traumatic time for you and your family
at a time when you know you need to keep
track of when you are supposed to do
things. It can be really challenging. Um
there's other use cases beyond this in
terms of chemotherapy when people have
trouble remembering what day it is, you
know, let alone what they're supposed to
be doing, right? You know, there there's
a variety of treatments that this is
relevant for. Um but AVA in particular
has a system that they use to help
people essentially administer these tele
medicine regimes at home right and um
that system is text message based so
everything here I'm going to show you is
essentially a text messaging based uh
engine with you know some some core
business logic um that helps people stay
on track it answers their questions. It
checks in on them you know to make sure
that the treatment went well. They still
have a doctor relationship. This isn't
replacing the doctor. it is simply
helping to get people through this
treatment without a doctor's direct
support at least a lot of the time. Um,
so a few disclaimers up front. First of
all, I'm going to show you a whole bunch
of stuff here that is is the is the
client's actual code. Um, thank you so
much to my client. Thanks to Aila for
being so open with this. It's really
awesome. I'm really happy to be able to
show you as much as I'm going to show
you. Um, I have redacted a few things.
Um, I think what's left is still, you
know, very much going to give you the
character of the whole thing and and an
idea of how it works. Um, Stride, we are
custom software people. So, we built
custom software. I I don't want to hide
that part, right? It's possible to do a
lot of this stuff with off-the-shelf
tools. Um, but there were some specific
requirements this client had that made
it better, frankly, to build a lot of it
custom. Um, so we did, but we did the
best we could to use, you know, big
swads of off-the-shelf, right? So,
you'll see a lot of Langraph, Langchain,
Lang Smith, you know, a bunch of other
things like that, you know, very much in
here because we do believe that that
adds value and that it fundamentally
makes the system a lot more explainable.
Um and you know there are also some
constraints in terms of how it's hosted.
This is you know at least partially
intersecting with with patient data and
various things like HIPPA and other
privacy requirements. Um the other thing
as I I started with earlier there's no
right way to do this but this one does
work for us and and I think you'll see
as we walk through it some of the
choices we made. Um you know there there
are definitely other ways we could have
plugged the tools together. I think
there's definitely other ways we could
have done this workflow. Um but but we
like how this came out. it it preserved
some of the things that we really knew
were important to our client and that
kind of reserve um you know a lot of
human judgment you know as opposed to
sort of taking the elements entirely at
their word and this is very much a
hybrid system with humans very much in
the loop um and again as I mentioned
before um I would really love it if you
guys looked at what we're doing here and
said that's dumb that or or have you
thought about this right because a you
know this is a project which we've only
been working on for a few months but you
know things have already evolved that's
the way it is in in AI. So I am certain
and I know of a handful of things where
you know we could replace some of the
choices we made with newer more modern
choices. Um and at the same time you
know there may be cases where you know I
I'm genuinely not using line graph.
Right. I I would love if someone raises
their hand and tells me that. So please
do uh have that in the back of your
brains.
Cool. Um really briefly on the stack
that we used and and on the team that we
built. So the first thing again there's
a lot of lang chain in here. Um that is
not because other frameworks can't do
this. It's not because we couldn't build
our own. The number one reason we went
with this is because of how easy it is
to explain the system to other people,
right? You know, if if you look at and
I'll show you the Langraph stuff in
particular. It it was straightforward to
go into our client, you know, on on a
very early day in the project and say,
"Hey, this is how this thing works. You
can see it goes from here to here.
There's loops here. Like this is where
we're doing our um you know, our our
evaluation of the process and here's
where humans come in." It was very
straightforward to do that. Um, and I
think it would have been a lot harder
with something that was less visual and
and frankly just less well orchestrated.
So, so we're happy with this, right?
There there are some trade-offs to the
the lang chain tools, but they're
they're mostly things we can live with.
Um, we are using uh Claude in the
examples that I'm going to show you
here. Um, but the the core code that we
wrote works with Gemini, works with
OpenAI. Um, there are a few reasons that
we think Claude is is better for this.
I'll get into that as we go. Um, but you
know, there's there's no model specific
stuff really happening here. This is
almost all just tool calling and MCP and
you know other things that are are
pretty portable across most of the
models.
Um the stack overall is not just the LM
piece, right? So the LM piece is Python
and a line graph container. Um and then
the the other piece, right, the piece
that is a text message gateway and a
database and a a dashboard, which I'm
going to show you pretty extensively is
Node and React and MongoDB and Twilio
and the whole thing is hosted in AWS.
None none of that has to be that way.
That's just what we picked. Um, you
know, the main reason we picked AWS was
for, you know, that this has to support
multiple different regions. We had to be
able to deploy stuff, you know, entirely
in Europe in a couple of cases, right?
And so, we needed to make sure that we
had, you know, a decent set of of, you
know, cloud connections that we could
work with.
Uh, eval. So, I will show you the the
eval system that we built. Um, we were
not able to use or at least I shouldn't
say not able. We chose not to use the
stuff um entirely off the shelf from
Langmith. This is partly because I
didn't really want to be fully locked
into them. I wanted the data to live
there. I wanted to be able to see, you
know, the current system in Langmith,
but I wanted to have something separate.
And it turns out that some of what we
had to do to make the eval um, you know,
fundamentally functional required a lot
of pre-processing. So, we built an
external harness that essentially pulls
data out of Langmith, processes it, and
then runs things through PromptFu. Um,
and one of the reasons we picked Prompt
Fu, if anyone's ever worked with it, um,
they have a very flexible, uh, they call
it an LLM rubric. And, and so this is an
LLM as a judge. you basically describe
how you want the the eval to work. Um
you feed the data in and you know then
it gives you a separate sort of
visualization for that. So we we ended
up very happy with it. It's not the only
way to do it at all. It was definitely
you know the the thing that fit best for
for us
uh the team. So there were uh and and
still are um two software engineers, one
designer um and me and and I'm just I I
would not call myself a software
engineer. That's why I didn't include
myself in that pool. You can imagine
there there being two software engineers
kind of maintaining the core system that
has the the gateway and the dashboard
and the text message stuff, right? And
and the database. Um I maintained and
and built basically everything on the
the Langraph side, right? So imagine
this as being two separate systems that
talk to each other through a well-
definfined contract. Um and that two
that those two software engineers
understand roughly how my code works,
but they really weren't maintaining it.
You know, it was it was almost entirely
me with uh AI friends. Um, and on that
note, so everything I'm going to show
you is the code that I wrote and and I
want to be very clear. Um, I haven't
been a real software engineer in a long
time. I do have an engineering
background. I spent seven years out of
college, you know, hacking on mobile
apps. Um, I took 15 years off and went
to be a product person and for about two
years now I've been back. But what that
really means is just that, you know,
essentially the stuff you're seeing,
right, or the stuff that I'm going to
show you is mostly, you know, code that
I wrote with Klein. That's that's my
personal favorite. Um, and so there's a
bunch of options here. I like client
best of all these options. Um, you can
use anything you want. The code isn't
actually that complicated. Like I would
estimate, and I I haven't actually
counted, but there's probably a few
thousand lines of Python and there's a
few thousand lines of prompt. It's it's
about equal, right? So I vibecoded the
Python and I mostly handcoded the
prompt. Um, not 100%, right? But but
that's that's the way to think about the
division of labor here. Um, and for that
matters, I mean, any of these tools can
be great. The main reason I picked Klein
was just because, you know, we did not
need u, you know, sort of a
hyperoptimized, you know, um, like $20 a
month flow. Like I've spent a lot more
than $20 a month on tokens. That's
that's just the way it is. Um, you know,
that it was worth spending the money to
just have sort of the best available
context of the model at any given point.
Um, client is a very good way to do
that.
Okay. And there's a little bit of of
sample code. So I did mention, and this
is in the Slack channel as well. If you
wanted to follow along with any of this,
you could sort of do it by standing up
your own little Langraph container with
MCP. you're more than welcome to do
that. Um, everything I'm going to show
you though is proprietary client code,
so I I obviously can't send you those
links. So, if you'd like to, um, feel
free to fire it up. Um, we have two
hours, which is a really long period of
time. If if you're interested in
spending a little time at the end of
this actually working with some of this
real code, I'm I'm thrilled to do that.
Um, so feel free to get yourself ready
in the meantime.
Okay, just a couple things up front just
to make sure we're level set in terms of
of sort of the terms and kind of the way
that we're talking about this stuff. So,
um, I do like the lang chain definition
here of of agent. Um, basically just
because, you know, you'll see what we're
doing here is using an LLM to control
the to control the flow, right, of of
this application. That is literally what
what this is. Um, and I like this and I
don't know if Chris is here. He he was
at the last event in New York. I like
this as a way of of sort of justifying
the way that we tried to architect this
system and why, right? So the idea of of
agents in production, right? You have to
know what they're doing. You have to
know, you know, that they can do it, and
you have to be able to steer, right? If
you only have a couple of these things,
you end up with with bad outcomes,
right? And so I I I just like this
framing of if you're capable, but you
can't tell what it's doing, it's
dangerous. If you know exactly what it's
doing, but you can't control it, it does
weird stuff and you can't help. Uh,
please go ahead. Bunch of us are looking
for the Slack channel. Oh, uh, let me
find that one more. It's right here
actually. workshop langraph MCP agents.
Got it. Okay,
no problem. Okay, but uh and so
transparency with no control is
frustrating and control with no
capability is useless. I I just love
this framing. I think this is exactly
the thing that we were trying to solve
for. We needed something that was able
to do the job, clear about what it was
doing, and that was steerable by humans
in a really obvious way. So, um with
that said, I'm going to start with a
case study, right? And this is going to
be a little weird out of context, but
hopefully this will give you a sense of
of what we were trying to solve for. So
the idea here was that there's there's
an existing product, right? So there was
a product out there that was essentially
having uh you know, humans manually push
buttons on a console that would enable
uh a text message to go out, right? So
you would read what the patient had
said. They could say, "I took my
medicine at 3 p.m." They could say, "I'm
bleeding and I don't know what's going
on. Like, am I okay?"
um they could ask other sorts of
questions about the treatment and a
human would have to go into a piece of
software and click you know a button
that accurately reflected sort of where
in the workflow somebody was right
because you know you can model a lot of
this out you know imagine there being
fantastically complicated flowcharts of
all the things that can happen during a
medical treatment um so the AIA team had
built this right they realized though
that essentially to scale the human team
to be able to serve a lot more patients
was prohibitive right they they needed
too many people clicking too many
buttons they also realized they couldn't
really scale the system to new
treatments, right, which was something
they wanted to do. That this isn't the
only regimen that you needed to support.
They had other ones. Um, and so the idea
is that either they were going to
rebuild the legacy software to be more
flexible or they were going to
essentially rebuild it to to to use a
different kind of decisioning at the
core. And and when they were looking at
doing this, you know, LLM had had
started, I think, become capable enough
to to handle this kind of of work. Um,
so what we built, what we did is we
built for them a workflow and
essentially a piece of software that
connects to it that enabled them to do
new treatments flexibly, right? So this
idea of essentially defining a blueprint
and a knowledge base is the way that we
we thought about this. Um, and and
essentially medically approved language,
right? So one of the reasons that you
had humans pressing buttons instead of
typing text messages is because this is
medical advice, right? You know, you you
are not um you should not at least be
giving medical advice um that differs
substantially from from this approved
language, right? there's reasons that
this stuff, you know, is said the way
that it's said. Um, you know, and and
doctors have, you know, similar
limitations. Um, we also built a
self-evaluation function, which I'll go
into tremendously, um, in a second. Uh,
we wanted to make sure that we caught
essentially situations that were
complicated, um, and surfaced them for
humans, right? Because we wanted to have
a human in the loop, but we were trying
to raise up the existing folks who were
really just operating the system and and
clicking all those buttons to be
supervisors of of agents that were doing
that instead, right? that that really
was the the model that we were working
with at its core. Saw a question over
here. Yeah, you may have said it. Were
these operators?
Uh so the question is are these
operators medically trained? There is a
physician's assistant who essentially
leads the operations team. So the way
that you can think about it is that um
she would be escalated to whenever
something came up that was outside of
the blueprint, right? So if you had a
situation where they're just like, I'm
really not sure what to do here, a Slack
goes out to that channel with a
physician's assistant in it who would
then give medical advice. So, you know,
again, this is one of the reasons it was
hard to scale, right? Because, you know,
you only had one of those people on this
particular team. Sure. Um, and so, you
know, to to sort of jump a little bit
ahead, but hopefully you'll see why this
is in a minute. This roughly and and
again, we're we're still doing the
measurement, right? We're still trying
to figure out exactly what, you know,
capacity has has gone up to. Um, we
think it's something like 10x. We think
that they can surface roughly 10x more
people with this new approach. Um, now
it's not free, right? We have to build
the software. we have to pay for the
tokens. Um tokens can get expensive. But
if you think about, you know, just the
scale issues involved in scaling up a
team of people and again in building the
software to be more flexible for more
treatments, um we think this capacity
increase is is very very much warranted
and very much the thing that that you
know solves solves the problem. Um and
you can do new treatments in new
workflows without writing more code.
Right? That was the single biggest thing
about this. And and you'll see what
we're doing here is largely Google Docs,
right? And you know, we have some more
advanced techniques to to manage those
things and inversion them over time, but
but we're talking about being able to
support whole new treatments and whole
new workflows without going back to the
code, right? That's hugely valuable to
these guys.
Question
you mentioned velocity
measuring quality of care. So question
was uh velocity increases. Is there a
quality of care measure? Um short answer
is it's early, right? I mean this is
still a system that's you know in
progress. it is being used with real
people, but it's still very very much
early on that the way that I think we're
looking at it is that there would be
some combination of the operators being
the ultimate arbiter, right? They're
going to be able to see these
conversations and determine as they
approve them, you know, as they review
them like, hey, is this mostly getting
it right? And then there there are sort
of existing kind of seesat, you know,
level measures that you can apply to the
people who are on the other end of the
treatment.
10x sounds a little low. Is that because
the operators don't approving everything
that comes out right now? uh so they're
not approving everything that comes out
and I agree the 10x is kind of it's an
order of magnitude not a precise measure
right but I think in this case you'll
see a couple of cases that require
approval right and sort of why but the
approval also is very quick right so I
the argument is that you probably only
see one of every 10 exchanges and when
you see it it takes you roughly as long
as it took the last time to just push
the button right which was the thing
they were already doing so that's kind
of why we've benchmarked it there
all right um so let's get into it a
little bit So, uh, this is just a
snapshot of of what this looks like in
Langraph. I'll show you the real thing
in just a minute, and it's actually
evolved a tiny bit since I took this
picture. Um, but really what we're
talking about here is, um, the the the
people who operate the system today, we
call them operations associates. So,
what this is really doing is introducing
a virtual operations associate. that
operations associate is going to assess
the state of essentially a conversation
interaction with a patient. Um determine
what the best response is both in terms
of uh the text message you might send um
the questions you might ask the actions
you might take because some of this is
about maintaining essentially a state
for that patient, right? you know, you
are you are at any given point trying to
figure out um when is this person taking
their medicine, when did they take their
medicine, um you know, what medicine do
they have? Um what time is it for them,
which is actually more important than
than you may think. Um all of this has
to be maintained, right, by the system.
And so the virtual lawyer is doing all
of that work and then it's passing
essentially its proposal, right? It it
basically comes up with I think this is
what we should do and it passes it to an
evaluator agent. There's a live LLM as a
judge process separate from the evals
which which we'll get to. But the live
LLM as a judge is essentially saying,
okay, given this thing that just
happened. Um here is our assessment of a
you know how right the LLM thinks it is.
Um that's frankly very challenging. LLMs
are very hard to convince that they're
wrong about anything. But um it also is
looking at the complexity, right? So
even if the LM believes it's made all
the right decisions, you can have it
impartially say, "Well, I changed this
and I changed that and I'm scheduling a
bunch of messages. That's complicated.
maybe a human should look at this,
right? So that's actually a lot easier
to implement. Um, and both of these
things are calling tools. The tools are
a mix of MCP. Um, and so there there's
sort of two versions of MCP here. I'm
going to show you one which is basically
just looking at local files just so I
can show you all the stuff in my
environment. Um, but there's also MCP
going across the wire to the the larger
software system and keeping all this
stuff in a database, right? So there's
there's a mix of those two things. Um,
and the rest of the tools are about
maintaining state because as a
conversation is happening, the the LLM
needs to know, you know, essentially,
well, I made this update and that update
and here's the current state that I'm
working with and it has to be able to
sort of manipulate these things in real
time. That is not MCP. That's not going
to a database anywhere. Like, this is
happening entirely in sort of the live
thread. And then once it finishes, then
it gets pushed out and and essentially
saved away.
Okay. Um, again, we'll get into a lot
more of that. I did want to spend a
minute on the on the system
architecture, right? And so I realize
it's a little bit small. Go ahead. When
you mention about the system state, I I
heard before the L has a context or some
state object.
You mention that you use tools. Are you
talking about separate things or uh
question was about how the state is
managed in Langraph. So um short answer
is this may be one of the things where
I'm not not doing it optimally by the
way but um with langraph there is a
state object that we load essentially
when the request comes in from a JSON
blob right we keep it alive inside the
the graph run it is not directly
accessible to the model right the at
least not the way that we're doing it
right so you you'll see actually as we
get into this that you can see all the
state coming in in Lang Smith right I
can see like hey this is the whole thing
that was was loaded I still have to
repeat that in my first message to
clawed right it doesn't actually show up
you know in the same place and then I
call the functions that state will
evolve in terms of what's inside the
graph run and then when it outputs it's
the it's the Python code not the model
which essentially takes all that state
and then uh serializes it and sends it
out. Um so you you'll see how it works
but like I that's generally one of the
things that I'm not sure I'm doing
right.
Anything else? Yep. Yeah. Somewhat
related. You have one node for that
virtual going back and forth tools right
now. Yeah. I'm assuming the reason you
haven't forcoded out that business logic
more into separate nodes is you'll lose
the workflow for the next time. Is that
sort of the notion there? Yeah. So the
question is why the essentially the
virtual A is one one agent not you know
a sort of a a precoded sort of version
of here's how I administer the specific
treatment. Yes. the the reason I think
we kept it simple is because we did not
want to be super treatment specific in
how the architecture worked. But you
could imagine doing, you know, a set of
slightly smaller, you know, better tuned
agents that were, you know, kind of
taking care of elements of the task that
was still pretty generic. The main
reason I think it's not optimal to do
that is is caching. Um, and this is
another question where, um, you know, I
I think I'm doing this right, but there
are a lot of variations here. um caching
the entire message stream is easier with
with either one agent or with sort of
one agent doing most of the work. Um
we're using Claude. Claude has very
explicit caching mechanisms. Um and
every time I switch the system prompt, I
think the cache blows up. And so
fundamentally changing the agent
identity does that. So that was one
that's one reason we chose that. It's
it's certainly not you know a hard and
fast forever choice.
What's the uh duration of the uh like we
talking like months or so like how many
messages? Yeah. So uh this use case the
early pregnancy loss um it tends to be a
treatment which takes I think three days
end to end to administer most of the
time and then there's a check-in after
that right so imagine that probably
within a week the entire interaction
with that patient is done unless they
come back and just have questions later
on right you know there there are some
variants of this where you take a
pregnancy test after six weeks right and
and so that's all fine um the message
history is preserved but the computation
that happens to generate each message is
not or at least not in not in sort of
the state that we behave. So like, you
know, the most complicated conversation
I've seen was something like 150 texts.
It's a lot in terms of, you know, a
human keeping it in their brain. It's
not that bad for an LM, right? So, but
it's it's that level.
All right. Um, so again, just to point
out where the lines are here, right? So,
as I kind of got off on a tangent, the
top box is what we're going to be
looking at here today, right? It's
really a Python container with access
locally to these blueprints, this
knowledge base, right? We are also then
maintaining some stuff over across the
wire in this blue container. That's
really where the the dashboard I'm going
to show you is. It's where the text
message gateway is. Um and it is where
we're going to be moving I think a lot
of that context, right? The blueprints
like all that stuff really should live
kind of in the more durable software
container. Right now it lives, you know,
close to to the Python.
Okay. Um so let's get into it. Um so the
first thing I'll do here is just to show
you uh kind of at a high level what the
software looks like. So um this again is
uh the the the console the dashboard
right the thing that that the operations
associates the humans are going to be
looking at um and I'll show a couple
things here just to to give you the the
sort of baseline right so the first
thing here is this needs attention so
the current system basically has this
needs attention flashing all the time
every time a text message comes in from
any patient this thing is going off
right you know so there and there's you
know hundreds of patients thousands of
patients in the system at any time so
you know this needs attention used to be
something that multiple people were
having to stare at constantly, right?
Just to make sure that they caught
everything so that they got out messages
in a in a reasonable time. Now, needs
attention is really, you know, just sort
of one thing at a time, right? And if I
look here at the conversations, there we
go. Um, you can see that the top one
here actually needs a response. I'll get
to that in a minute. But at any given
point, right, this is my test
environment. You know, I've got a
handful of these conversations kind of
already already queued up. What I can
see here, if I click into these things,
is essentially I'll just go back to the
beginning here for the the whole message
history, and I'm going to toggle this
rationale on. Um, what you're seeing is
the entire conversation. Is that
readable? So, I blow it up a little bit.
Is that a little better? Okay. Um, so
the idea here is, uh, the agent is named
Ava, right? That's the personality that
people are interacting with. Um, this
language is all coming out of these
blueprints, right, that I'll show you.
And so this first message is just an
initial message sent by the system
essentially just to kick things off. So
imagine someone is they have a package
of medicine in their hand. They scan a
QR code. They put in their phone number,
they get this text message, right? And
then they start talking. Um, so you can
see here the kinds of things a patient
is going to say are, you know, free form
text, right? You know, this I mean they
could say yes in any number of ways. The
old system used to have literally
different buttons for yes, like yes, I
have the medicine. Yes, I heard you. I
mean, it's like there's all sorts of
variants, right? And because you you did
have to respond differently depending on
what those things were. What we're able
to do here is really just take, you
know, these free form answers, interpret
them, and then essentially provide a
rationale for why you would say a given
thing at a given time, right? So, this
is equivalent to if you were doing this
with a human and you ask the human,
well, why did you say this? The LM can
provide this kind of of context. So,
this is Claude looking at the history
here, and I I'll show you what this
looks like in Langmith, which will make
it a lot more obvious. And then saying,
okay, here here's the next thing that I
should say. And my confidence that I
should say it is 100%. Right? It's it's
usually very confident, right? But but
the point is this this whole process is
largely going to go along in an
automated fashion, right? You don't
usually need humans involved because
this is a very straightforward thing.
They have their medicine. The next thing
I need to know, and this is a very
interesting part of this treatment, I
need to know what time it is. These are
text messages. We don't know anything
about these people for a variety of
reasons. It's kind of good that we don't
know much about them, right? We don't
want to have to deal with all of the
stuff around provider confidentiality
and and patient data, right? So, one of
the things that we need if we're going
to go through this longitudinal
treatment is to figure out what time it
is for them and then essentially pull
out that data and figure out what their
local time is. Right? So, in this case,
I was in Eastern time when I answered
these questions. This is all me doing
this, you know, from my laptop. Um, I
tell it what time it is. It calculates
an offset from UTC and says, "Well, I
guess you're in Eastern time, right?"
And then it sets this over here and it
says, "All right, from now on, I know
that my patient is in Eastern time
unless they tell me otherwise." And they
could come back and tell you otherwise,
right? That's something the old system
really didn't have a good way to do. Um,
but if the patient comes back and says,
"I'm on a plane. It's actually seven for
me." We just update the time zone and
move on. Right? This is a very flexible
system that way. Um, then we get into
this over here and we say, "Okay, now
that I know what time it is, I'm going
to ask them if they've started their
treatment, right?" And, you know, there
is a blueprint, right, which we'll get
to, you know, that essentially just has,
you know, the the medicine that they're
going to take in a very specific way to
take it, right? The the protocol. Um,
the patient says, "Well, no, I want to
take it soon." You know, the Ava says,
"Cool. I'll text you when we're ready."
And then it gives you know a regimen
which in this case this is an SVG that
we are stapling times and dates on top
of right so you know fairly
straightforward we're doing this in
software the LM's not doing it the LM is
actually just passing along the
instructions you know it says send the
step one image and provide you know like
this date and this time and and we
substitute the rest of it in and this
goes out as an MMS right so this is this
is a text message um and so we provide
this the patient you know says you know
in this case we're we're talking you
know again this is all the LM reasoning
through this, right? You know, I I I am
sending this immediately because it's
actually within sort of the 35 minute
window that you've told me that I have
to send these things. This is all
business logic that the LLM is is
interpreting pretty much on the fly. Um,
and then I have these reminders, right?
I didn't get back to it. So, this is an
important part. It sent me this thing
and it thought that I was going to take
it at 5:45. I didn't text it back,
right? This is partly because I was m
maintaining the system myself and I
forgot. So, I had to come back in the
next day and catch up. Um, so it sent me
an automated reminder because it
scheduled one when it sent the first
message. So part of this is the LM only
gets called when the patient says
anything. So if they don't, you know,
you have to make sure that you stay
engaged, right? You don't do this overly
like we don't try to bother people
beyond one or two reminders. It's their
treatment. Um, but this bump sort of
functionality was really important to
the client, right? So we built it in.
Um, so you can see here I came back the
next day and I said, "Yep, sorry. I I
did take it." You know, Ava confirms
that I completed step one. And what it
does is it sets this thing called an
anchor, right? And it says, okay, you
know, the patient was going to take it
at 5:45, they confirmed that they did.
And so now, you know, I can refer back
to this. I know that this happened,
right? And if the patient had then said,
oh no, I screwed up. I actually haven't
taken. I'll take it today. We just
change the anchor. We update everything.
Right? So this is a system that humans
used to have to do. If a patient came
back and said, I didn't take my
medicine, you know, a human has to go in
and manually update all the times and
all the scheduled messages. And it was
it was a big pain in the butt. Um, yeah,
please.
implement this functionality where
patient report
state
not exactly um the way that we do state
and I'll I'll spend a lot of time on
this but the way that we do state is
really just that with any given message
from the patient right this entire
system only kicks off when the patient
sends a message um what we do is we say
all right given this state what is the
best response and that response could be
I changed some of these anchors. I
update their treatment phase. I I
schedule a bunch of messages. All that
state is preserved so that the next time
they write in, then you know, we have
that state to go on. Um, but again,
we're not checking, right? There's no
polling going on in the system where
we're saying after 3 hours, did the
patient text me back? We we don't do
that. We depend on the scheduled
messages essentially just to nudge the
patient. Um, if they choose to not say
anything for three days and they come
back after three days, we just pick up
where we left off. Um, again, this is a
choice. This is the way the client wants
it. It's it's intended to be low enough
touch that it doesn't bother people, but
high enough touch that it doesn't lose
track.
Sure. Um I'll pause here actually. Any
other questions so far? Um I I realize
I'm going through a lot. Yes. Do your
anchors have to be sequential or can
your user come in at any point?
They can. Great question. So the
question was do the anchors have to be
sequential? Um or like do you have to go
through these one step at a time? So,
one of the great things, one of the best
things about this system is that I could
have and and I'm happy to try this when
we go a little bit later. I could have
basically said, "Oh, yeah. I already
took the first pill and I'm like in the
middle of taking the second pill, you
know, as like the first thing I say to
to Ava and she would be like, "Okay,
cool. There's an anchor. Here's the next
thing." It skips ahead and it doesn't
force you to go through this
prescriptive part of the blueprint,
whereas the old system, you know, at
least nominally did, right? Like you
could you could kind of skip ahead, but
this automatically does it. You know,
part of the instructions are don't ask
the patient a question they've already
answered. Like, period, right? But
that's annoying. Don't do that. Um, so
so yes, that's that's very much in
there.
Anything else? Yeah. Does the
concept of the internal state machine
that is kind of determining all of this
or is that kind of outsourced to the
actual software?
Yeah. So question is, does the LM have
an internal representation of the state?
Um, kind of sort of. So you'll you'll
see um when we get into the the the
actual back and forth with Claude um in
Langmith you as a human can see kind of
where it starts right so every thread is
going to show like all right here's the
incoming state we repeat it essentially
to claude again that's just one dot I've
never managed to connect with lang graph
right so we basically have to serialize
the state and say this is your this is
your starting point but then the LM has
that in its window and then you know
it's going to cause changes to the state
it'll call functions that update the
state it can always ask again it can say
well what's the current state you I can
go back and and retrieve it. Um, but in
the context of that one from when the
patient responded, you know, to when I
actually come up with my response to
them, that whole thing is going to be in
its memory at one moment.
Did you ever run into issues with state?
Um, so the the short answer is the
question was um, do we ever run into the
state being too big? uh generally
speaking because of the way that we're
kind of compressing and serializing at
the end of the conversations it doesn't
ever get so big that it can't finish its
job of responding to one situation right
you know like patient said this now I'm
going to do this we have considered
having longer running threads where you
kind of pick up in the middle and you've
already you can reload sort of the
entire previous conversation that does
get weird right especially with older
clouds you would get it forgetting to
sort of call tools the right way and it
have all sorts of JSON errors right we
have a bunch of retry logic in there to
kind of compensate for that. Um, so
that's one reason we kept it short. We
make it so that we basically throw
everything out and restart when the
patient gets back to us. In part because
blueprints could change, right? You a
bunch of things could could change in
the meantime that might end up with with
weird states.
So on the management of states and
taking decisions what to do next. Yeah.
So this is 100% LLM driven or there's
some softer like logic around it as
well. It's 100% LLM driven. Uh sorry the
question was uh is the is the steering
done by software right any any of that
steering the answer is really no it's
not um except for when it surfaces to a
human right and so when it goes to a
human for approval the human can use
English and basically say yeah change
that word to that and that message
shouldn't go out and you know whatever
so like we we actually as part of the
flexibility part we are not building any
software that manages the state we just
want you to talk to the LM to do it
right we think that's a better practice
right it means like you know you as a
human just have to talk to it and you
don't have to figure out how to flip all
the bits on this new console.
Do you have any rack system? And second,
if a patient going off journey, how do
you detect that?
I'm sorry, what was the first question?
Do you have any rack system
or Rex? I'm sorry, I just understand.
Retrieval. Oh. Oh, got it. Sorry. So,
um, question was, is there a rag? Uh,
no, there's not. And and it's actually
just because what we really did is we
just came up with a structure for the
documents that was self-reerential. So
you read a very small document which
says here's the treatment, right? If you
need to read for this phase, go to this
file, right? If you need for this phase,
go to this file. If you have a question
that doesn't fall underneath any of
those things, here's a CSV with a bunch
of questions and answers. We didn't do
it as rag in part because we didn't
believe that e either we could do a
really good job of getting all the right
information into the window. Like we
didn't think we'd be reliable enough
about that. We just want to give the
entire document. They're not that big.
Um, and because these this is clawed,
right? It's it's got a big enough window
that we could just put the entire thing
in there, you know, for for most
treatments. So, we chose to do that.
What was your second question, though?
Is the patient going off a typical
journey? Yeah. How do you detect and
intercept? Right. So, the question is if
the patient goes off track, so we we
have this idea of a blueprint, but then
there are plenty of cases where the
blueprint may um you know, not fully
answer whatever the patient is is is
bringing up. Um like one example is the
blueprint is very much about asking
questions right so you will say have you
taken your medicine yet when do you plan
to take your medicine the patient will
say my stomach hurts okay so yes your
stomach hurts you didn't answer the
question what we do is the patient
typically will get an answer to their
question so one of the principles is
always answer the patient's question
right we don't ever want to leave them
hanging but then ask yours again so the
idea is that at any given point we can
answer anything that they need and as
gently as we can we'll try to pull them
back onto the blueprint so that we
understand where they are in the
treatment. Um, it's in exact science.
But, uh, is there a way to detect if
someone
Well, the LM does that effectively by
knowing that it's supposed to keep
people on the blueprint, but having an
escape hatch for the knowledge base,
essentially what we call it, right?
Triage or knowledge base, you know,
whatever you want to call it. Um, so,
you know, we we don't have an explicit
bit sort of flipped in the system that
will say this patient is off track. We
just kind of know roughly where they are
in the treatment and if they want to
answer if they want to ask a bunch of
questions we we'll just answer them
until they they are satisfied.
Okay. Uh yeah.
Yeah.
So question is why did we choose
langchain and would we still um I I will
be very candid that the main reason that
I chose lang chain is that I had
personally gotten pretty comfortable
with langraph as as a a demonstration of
these concepts right it's not that crew
I mean we did a lot of autogen work back
in the earlier days right you know I've
done a little bit with crew AI all of
those frameworks can functionally do
very similar things langraph was the
absolute best at explaining to people
who were not neck deep in this stuff how
it worked um and because there was a
path to production From there, I didn't
feel a need to to replplatform and
change all of it. We certainly thought
about it, right? We considered, well,
what if we didn't do this in Langraph?
What would we gain? And but the answer
is you still have to implement
observability in certain ways. You know,
you don't necessarily get, you know, the
support that you might get from
Langchain if you end up in a place.
Remember that we're also doing this for
clients. We're not going to be there
forever. Um, leaving them with something
that they can call, you know, somebody
to to support is also a helpful aspect.
So, I think I I I don't think I do it
differently. I think it's really just
that you know ultimately you know we're
getting pushed all of us in the
direction of using the native model
tools for this right you know openai has
the responses API which lets you define
tools cloud has its new stuff right like
I don't really want to be locked in um I
I I am to some degree locked into lang
chain now but I I prefer that honestly
to being locked into the models um these
are these are not performance intensive
things we're doing in terms of the
software right like you know I don't
care that lang chain is sometimes a
little slow um I would rather have the
option
So you said you're not using
the scale how
those
uh it is just that they have sorry the
question was about um if it's not rag
how do we fetch documents the documents
refer to each other so you'll see that
we have an overview MD right this is all
in markdown um there's an overview md
that tells you what other documents are
involved in the treatment right there's
some of the prompting which says you can
always request a triage overview, right,
to to try to handle problems. Um, and
it'll be there, right, regardless of
what the treatment is. So, it it is very
much just a document management thing.
Um, rag, the main issue is just that I I
don't think and and you know, this will
probably be more obvious as we get into
it, right? I don't think that you could
really design a rag which would pull
back snippets of everything in sort of
perfectly relevant relevant ways. You
really do kind of need to understand the
shape of the whole treatment, right? to
to make a good decision, right?
Otherwise, you're just going to pair it
whatever particular snippet the rag
happened to bring back and then the
logic all has to be in the rag. It makes
more sense and it's more transparent, I
think, to do it this way. Maybe you'll
get to this in the state management
later on. Are anchors predefined in the
blueprint or are they
they are mostly predefined by the
blueprint and that we say as part of the
overview, you know, the concept of an
anchor is that it is a thing that
happened or a thing that will happen and
here are the examples for this
treatment, right? This is the thing that
will happen or did happen in this
treatment. Sorry that was questions
about the anchors. Yeah. So when you
you mentioned that you conversation and
you keep track
uh no so that the state is essentially
um you know we we call it for reasons
that only an engineer could love. We
call it a schedule document. Right? The
idea is that for any given patient there
is a schedule that they're on and the
document snapshots their current state
at a given point. Right? And it's a
version database. So we could go back in
time and we could see what their
document was 3 days ago. Um but it has
at any given point the messages that
have been exchanged, any unscent
messages that are scheduled and enough
state about their treatment to fill out
this view. Yeah. Uh yeah.
So in this case all of this stuff is
locked away, right? So I mean just to go
back to this diagram for a second um
this entire thing is all behind you know
AWS's VPC right so like there is no
external access to the LLM period the
only things it can talk to are
essentially its own documents you know
in in local files and to the the blue
box so you know there there certainly
are vectors but the vectors would be
through the text messages right not
really through anything else
uh yeah oh I'm sorry bunch of people you
first question regarding I guess it's
twofold
is like how are you assessing the
confidence rate from the model's
response and the second is how are you
safe to get injection for malicious
behavior yeah well so uh question was
about prompt injection and generally
sort of steering um I mean the the basic
answer is just that
you could definitely try to trick the
model by sending weird texts right and
and we do that as part of our you know
sort of internal red teaming like we
have the entire team of operations
associates who have been spending you
know weeks and months trying to trick
this thing um and granted they're not
trying to trick it from a reveal
proprietary personal medical data, you
know, I mean, there there's things like
that. We also obscure a lot of that
medical data. So, the things that get
get to the yellow box do not include
phone numbers. They do not include
anything other than the patient's
identified first name. Um, so there's a
lot of there's a lot of that data that's
kept only in the blue, which is a lot
easier to to defend against. Um, so
yeah, we we we very much do obscure the
the the patient. We don't obscure the
treatment, right? The treatment is fully
visible to the LM. Yeah. Cool. Yep.
Yeah. Hold that thought. I will get to
that very very shortly. Um, we're back
there.
Uh, sorry. It's just a question about
unclear instructions. Um so uh when when
the situation is ambiguous the LLM is
told to look at the blueprint and pick
the best possible answer. Now if you
don't believe the LMU if you don't
believe the the answer is perfect um you
should say so right in the rationale. So
if I go back over here this idea of the
rationale if there is uncertainty on the
model's you know point of view it can
say well I picked this blueprint
response but I'm not sure that it's
right. In practice it's not great at
doing that right but that is the idea.
And then the evaluator is also going to
look at this and say, well, did you
actually pick either the exact blueprint
response word for word? Did you adapt
it? You know, does this seem right to
you? Like we're trying to at least give
a little bit of a layer before we get to
humans. And then hopefully we we can
trap situations like that and say, well,
this is a complicated situation. A human
should should take a look. Um, it is not
an exact science though, like that's
generally just true with this stuff.
Sorry, you in the back.
Yeah. Um so the question was just about
load and scale. So uh the look the
really short answer is that this this
system exists right there's an existing
version of it that is humans pushing
buttons. Um that scale is you know again
let's say thousands not millions of
patients. Um this opens up the
possibility of doing more treatments
right? That's how we would get sort of
additional patient scale. You can also
sell this to new hospitals, new clinics,
things like that. Um so part of this is
to get the scale to be larger. Um we
have not run into scale issues with you
know just the the conversations with
claude. You know the software that we're
building would scale much much larger
than thousands of users right you know
the the text message gateway might
actually be the the biggest bottleneck.
So it's it's honestly it's a problem we
want to have. Um go ahead. So um you
keep saying did you guys select thems
or was there like a specific reason why
you're going with 35 or whatever you
Yeah. Uh so questions of model selection
um when we started this right and and I
think you know let's assume that we
kicked this project off you know late
last year early this year right um we
had to make a choice and our main
criteria were it had to be a steerable
model that we felt pretty good about you
know transparency wise um you know one
example just just to give you a specific
one mini is pretty good at this workflow
but it won't show its reasoning um like
I mean that's just one example and like
it's not a dealbreaker like we can still
see the rationale like there's some
pieces of it but I like being able to go
into lang seeing the whole conversation,
right? That that really helps me out.
Um, we needed, you know, again, flexible
hosting, but I mean, all the clouds kind
of do that. Frankly, we didn't want to
deal with Microsoft and we kind of
preferred AWS to Google. That that was
kind of how we got there. But, you know,
you can do this anywhere. It really was
just we had to pick a horse and we
largely have not regretted it and in
part because we built enough flexibility
where if I want to switch, I I still
can.
Yeah.
Yeah. Uh so the question was about
sensitivity of data through the text
carriers and also about uh using the
data to learn. Um I'll do the learning
first. um we don't we we do not take any
of the responses and and do anything to
the models other than when we see
situations that we as humans have
evaluated and found wanting um we can
tweak the prompting and the guidelines
right but we are not putting this in any
sort of durable form like ultimately you
know we believe the right model here is
the provider interaction if there's a
provider involved that sticks around
right the provider knows that you
interact with the system they can have
you know whatever records they need um
otherwise you know we forget about you
when your treatment is done we think
it's better that way um on the on the
the sensitivity question. Yes, there is
sensitivity involved and at the same
time again there's prior art with these
products, right? There are existing
systems which essentially take, you
know, text messages in and provide
medical advice. Um, we're just trying to
stay within the guidelines of that. And
again, that's one reason why we don't
want the LLM actually to have any data
that is not explicitly required just to
do decisioning, right? It doesn't need
anything beyond that to to make a good
decision.
Okay.
Yeah.
every response is 100% determining that
that's 100% what situations where that's
notified. Yep. Sorry. Hold that thought
too because I will get to that in just a
second. Um let me move on. Uh please
like bring these questions back up. I
just want to get a little bit further so
we can see some other some other cool
things about this. Um I'm going to move
on from this flow just because you can
imagine that this is going over a period
of days, right? There's another step
here, step two, where there's, you know,
more medicine being dispersed. Um and
then, you know, ultimately we're going
to get to the end, right? and you know
essentially did you complete this and
then okay great you know this is what's
going to happen to you you know you're
going to see some bleeding um and then
we have this check-in right so imagine
that this now is you know a full let's
say three or four days later right after
the the treatment has begun um you know
we check in you know the patient gets
back to them or not right remember some
of these patients will just be like I'm
done I don't really need to talk to this
thing anymore but if they do right we
continue with the treatment we don't
bother them we just let them sort of
resume where they left off again we have
these rationes you know we have these
questions and then what I want to do
here is just to show you briefly um
sorry I got to zoom back out so I get
the full phone number um what it would
look like to interact. So if I go here
into my sandbox um imagine that normally
this would be a text message um so you
know I would be doing this on my phone
um but here you know I can answer this
question if I had any pregnancy systems
before have they decreased it's like yes
uh they have decreased
okay so I post this message now what's
going to happen from here is thinking so
none of this is instant and so now what
I want to show you is what this looks
like in Langmith so um you can see here
a couple of things um one is that this
this is now spinning. Um, so this thing
that I just asked it is now in active
processing. I'll show you what it looks
like when we're done. Um, but I will
give you just a brief look at um I think
this is probably a useful one here.
Um, what this actually looks like in
terms of processing the state. Um, so
I'll blow this up a little bit and make
it a bit bigger. So um, what you can
imagine this is using sonnet 4. Um, is
that every time a message comes in from
a patient, this is what I get. Okay, I
get this description of, you know,
everything that's going on here. I can
see this is an AVLA patient. I can see
the thread that we're currently
executing, right? Because you may need
to resume these threads if you need to
give feedback. Um, I have this idea of
I'm in the 3-day check-in phase. So,
that's the blueprint that I'm going to
read. Um, and then I have a couple of
things. I have these anchors, right,
which, you know, you could see. I think
this is exactly what you saw before. Um,
you know, in that same patient. Um,
these are all defined as, you know,
actually a mix of UTC and and Eastern
time stamps. Um, that's one of the
problems that's hard to eradicate. Um,
getting LM to deal well with time is
really tough. Um, but then I have this
entire message queue, right? And this is
the compressed state of the conversation
to date, right? This does not include
every message that Claude sent itself
while it was thinking, right? That part
is contained in these individual
Langsmith threads. I could go back and I
could look at this if I needed it. Um,
but what I'm doing is I'm compressing
and basically saying all I really care
about is the actual messages that went
back and forth. I want these rationale
because I want to be able to review
them, right? that helps me understand
the decisioning that's going on here.
Um, you know, I want these confidence
scores so I can go back and look, you
know, what did it think at any given
point? And again, I'll show you one
where the confidence was low. But these
things can go on a little ways, right?
This is probably, I don't know, 20 25
messages, right? All of this goes in as
initial context in the window, right?
So, if you had 150 messages, all 150 of
them are going to potentially go in.
Now, we do have a function where you can
optionally set it to compress and say,
well, just show me the last 50, right?
If I need to request more, I can do
that. There's a way to do it. Um but I
don't need to have the entire thing in
the window. Um so I get down here. This
is the last message from the patient.
Right? So the question was did you
notice blood clots? I said yes a few.
Right? You know that was that was what I
as a patient said. Claude is now going
to start processing this thing. Right?
So imagine you know this all being
basically pasted into you know a claude
window and then having it go through
this process and and call tools. So it
starts by looking at directories that
it's allowed to view. Again, this is a
version where it's got the blueprints
kind of all local and and it's it's
talking to them this way. We have
another version where it talks via MCP
over to the the blue box, right? The
larger system. Um, so it figures out
what directory it has. It reads these
basic ones because these need to be read
in all cases. So these guidelines,
right, the idea of how do you do your
job, right? The idea of what the
confidence framework looks like, the
overview of the treatment, right? You
know, those sorts of things. We read
those up front. None of these is very
large, right? And so you read all this
stuff, you know, it it comes into the
the window. Um, and then you know
essentially it reads those descriptions
and it says well I was told as part of
this that I have to read the current
blueprint for this current phase, right?
So I read that file individually. So a
bunch of these early calls are just
about setting up the context. This is
not the only way to do it, right? I I
mean this this is the way that we've
chosen to do it. Again, we chose not to
do rag for a couple of, you know,
reasons around we just did not think we
could get good enough results and
because this is honestly easier to
interpret, right? You can sort of tell
what it's doing. Um, I get to the
blueprint. the blueprint. And you we'll
we'll see more of these examples in a
second, but the blueprint is basically
this kind of structured bulleted list,
right? Here's all the stuff that you
might need to say to somebody, right?
And you know, here's what you do when
you know the user says a certain thing.
This isn't actually that prescriptive.
It's just structured, right? This isn't
an if then statement, right? It it's
kind of like that, but it's not an
actual if then statement. So, like this
format, you know, is one that we
iterated on and got to a point where we
actually get really good results. Um,
but you know, it wasn't 100% obvious
this is the way to do it up front. Um,
you know, we started with charts. Um,
and so now you get to this point where
now you can see, okay, now I got to look
at these, you know, uh, conversations. I
got to figure out what's been going on
here. And so you can see here, even
though I passed in the state, it has a
function to list messages. And so it
basically says, all right, well, now
that I sort of know what's going on, let
me see the last five messages, right?
And you can see here it's going to start
sending, you know, a bunch of these in.
Um, and so it does that. It looks to see
if there's anything scheduled. There's
not, right? And so now it says, "All
right, this is this is sort of the point
where Claude does its little explaining
thing. I understand what's going on.
Patient's in the three-day check-in
phase. I already asked about bleeding
and cramping. I I asked about blood
clots, and the patient, you know,
basically just said yes, they have blood
clots, and so I'm I'm just going to keep
on going, right?" And it goes to the
next question about pregnancy systems.
This message comes directly from the
blueprint. Okay? And and I'll show you
in a Google Doc form in a second what
that looks like. Um, so it schedules it.
that says you should send this message,
you know, as as soon as you want to. And
then we get over to this evaluator flow,
right? And the evaluator says, "All
right, I'm going to look at this
situation. I'm going to look at
everything that requires confidence
scoring, right? That new message is the
only thing. It's it's the the only thing
that just happened. Um, and I'm going to
send it immediately. This is just a a
time stamp for immediately. Um, I then
get this kind of report, right? And the
way that we set up our framework, um,
and and I'll show it in code a little
bit clearer is, you know, do we know
what the user is saying? Do we know what
to say and do we think that we did a
good job? Again, this is a tough one,
right? Um, generally speaking, the LLM,
you know, says at all times, "Yes, I
know what I'm doing." And, you know,
like buzz off. Um, but what I can also
do is I can say, "All right, then
there's a bunch of cases in which if I
set an anchor, if I updated the
patient's data, like maybe I changed
their time zone offset, maybe I changed
their name, right? That's a weird thing
that, you know, if it happened, you'd
probably want a human to look at. Um, do
I am I sending multiple messages? Do I
send a am I sending duplicate messages
accidentally? Do I have reminders for
things that have already happened? All
of those things would deduct from the
score and cause a human to get involved.
Right? That that's part of how we do
this is to combine does the model think
it's okay? Right? That's this top part.
And then overall, is there a weird
circumstance that I should try to catch,
right? And that I should try to to to
show people uh to show a human for
review. Um in this case, nothing came
up. I update the confidence. It's
confidence of 100%. Um, and then
essentially the virtual OA, you know, as
as a final thing, it's very hard to get
Claude not to summarize itself. It does.
Um, it basically just says here's
everything I did. I'm good. And then if
you go down here to the bottom, this is
the output state. So this output state
says, well, I have 100% confidence,
again, its version of it, that I did the
right thing. I, you know, here's my
anchors, here's my messages, and here's
the unscent message that I'm I'm now
going to send. And because it's 100%
confidence, it just goes out, right? it
goes back to the text message gateway
and it just goes out. Um, that is a
risk, right? You know, if you wanted to
be perfectly safe, you have a human
review all of these things. We don't
want to do that because we're trying to
scale, right? So, we are comfortable in
general with things that are are, you
know, coming back with 100% confidence
that we just send those messages out.
Uh, question back there. Yeah.
Yeah.
having trouble
later on. Uh yeah, so the question is
just uh how do we determine sort of the
the the the situations that might have
confidence issues? Um it is very
handtuned and geared to this evaluation
team like basically the virtual OA team
that exists now as as humans. Um we will
review you know in sort of spot checks
you know a bunch of situations just to
kind of see like hey is does this seem
like it's okay? um when the when a
patient writes back because there are
cases where a patient will write back
and say you got that wrong like that's
not the time I said like you know I'm
actually taking it now um the confidence
system is pretty good at picking up that
that happened and basically saying all
right even if I think I'm confident
something's wrong right you know a human
should take a look at this um but I mean
the the answer is it's it's more art
than science it's not something that we
are perfect at even now and because we
want to scale we've chosen to say look
the the worst that happens is
essentially something weird happens and
a couple of text messages go back and
forth that are just wrong. Usually the
human will get involved and say that
doesn't sound right to me. Right. It's
not it's not a case where the patient is
in danger. Um you know if they say well
I'm having these symptoms you're not
helping me. Like a human will step in.
Like that's that's something we're
pretty good at flagging. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean so the the short
answer is um we can look at interactions
that ultimately are scored as low
confidence and then we can trace back
from there right so a lot of what we're
doing is when something gets flagged and
a human is like well there's something
weird here um you know we share those
things internally right the the Slack
channel that I was talking about before
where they talk to the physicians
assistant that's largely been repurposed
to people saying hey this behavior is
off like can you go take a look and that
ends up essentially in my queue as you
know I got to go check my evals I got to
see if there's something I can do to
catch this and maybe it's a matter of
changing the behavior here. But so it's
usually it when we when we know there's
an issue, we can backtrack. That's the
short answer. Uh over here, I'm curious,
humans also make mistakes. Yep. Do you
have any data from
like%
of human responses versus AI? Yep. The
question was about human versus AI error
response from prior data. So yeah, great
question and and yes, the answer is we
do have that data and that's one of the
reasons that the client is as
comfortable as they are with letting an
LLM kind of run a muck, right? Is the
idea that humans do make mistakes now
and when they get escalated, you know,
it's something where you can look back
and be like, "Oh yeah, that was a little
bit off." You you correct it and you
move on. Um this is kind of unique and
that again it it needs to be, you know,
precisely worded like one of the biggest
risks is just that you give sort of off
label medical advice. But if the idea is
that like, oh, you misunderstood and you
have to go back and correct yourself.
That's okay, right? It's it's that's not
a fatal error, right? So, a lot of it is
that, you know, we think that we can get
better use out of our humans by
reviewing these situations, you know,
than we can out of just having them push
the buttons because they will
occasionally push buttons wrong, right?
Same thing happens as as with the
robots. So, um talking about mistakes
and this has been running for a while.
Yeah. Have you thought about fine-tuning
a model with deidentified messages like
running it back through? Yeah, I mean
the the
so the question was about um how we
thought about fine-tuning. Um we have
already seen two major model releases in
the time we've been working on this. Um
we we generally don't think that
fine-tuning is a great use of our of our
dollars. Um it it obviously it could be
cheaper. We I mean one one example is um
we tried you know at one point to use
Haiku um and you know Haiku is not even
that much cheaper. It's maybe a third
the cost right um we we got to a point
where we made our blueprints better in
part because like we'd sort of had some
shortcuts where we just didn't have to
be as as precise with sonnet right you
know we had to be more precise with hiku
and then it worked. Haiku did not get
the time stuff. Haiku was terrible at
figuring out what times it needed to
sort of put on things. And so the the
kind of thing we would have to do there
like it either just kind of requires a
smarter model and there were smarter
models from multiple people like 04 mini
really is both you know I mean it's c it
costs a little bit less than haiku I
think right and it it was every bit as
smart as sonnet we chose not to go with
it in part because it wasn't as
transparent um but so in in general we
don't believe that fine-tuning is
warranted because we think the models
are just going to keep getting better
and cheaper and that we you know we'll
be able to kind of switch wholesale as
opposed to having fine tuned something.
So when you're going through that sort
of you had this like chattiness with the
model where it was describing its
actions and then calling tools. Is that
like is that an intentional choice? I
feel like you could just skip that just
outputs it. Well so yes it was it was
kind of intentional choice right this is
partly that we we already get the the
rationale and sort of the general you
know explanation of its actions. Um but
there are times where you want to be
like look why did it do this and you
know if it's thinking out loud it's a
lot easier to catch. Um, so yes, it's
possible that we could eradicate some of
that. We don't really think the juice is
worth the squeeze.
Most likely you're going to suffer a
secondary. How does the current
structure set up so that you have a new
anchor point to see this person?
Yep. Uh, great question. So, uh,
questions about essentially multiple
treatments or coming back again after,
you know, having gone through a
treatment. Um, there are a couple ways
to do that. So one is that um you know
again depending on how you get there if
you scan a QR code that can start kind
of a new activation so we can know that
you're coming in a second time. Um but
people will write back after you know
two months and say I have a question
right and and so we either can just
reactivate that conversation. The other
thing is different treatments would
usually come from different phone
numbers. So there's a few different ways
to kind of disambiguate you know what
somebody's actually up to. But that
notion of like you know the same thing
happened to me again. I'm starting the
regimen over again. Fundamentally, you
could just explain it. You just say
like, "Hey, I had a miscarriage two
months ago. I had another one. Can you
help me?" And it would reset itself,
right? The LM is smart enough to do
that.
Can I share some
uh please? Because there's plenty to
there's plenty to share.
I mean intentionally obviously the
intention of improving two
intent I guess I'm skeptical that
doubling the costs are yielding
better
question you have like a funnel of how
often the evaluator might be second
question
they're both right in this case they are
yes is there was there
an intentional decision to stick with
rather than switching model where in
theory hypothetically you got a
different brain looking at the other
thing. Yep. And last question, sorry.
No, no, please. Um, was the inclusion of
this eval?
So, were there other impacts besides
just like this is a performance thing
that made it rigid? Yeah, so questions
are all about sort of the evaluator node
and the and the processes. So, uh, the
the shortest possible answer is, um,
yes, we're also skeptical about it. And
at the same time, we think that there's
still value in trying, you know,
essentially it's given getting a second
bite at the apple, right? We do think
that just having a different system
prompt in the same conversation does
occasionally deliver better results, but
you could have the the virtual OA
evaluating the complexity of its own
situation. I don't think you could get
it to evaluate whether it was right or
not, just typically LM are terrible at
that anyway. So I think the I think the
basic answer though is that we wanted
the flexibility in part so we could do
things like try a different model
entirely, right? Or you know have
something where maybe you maybe you did
fine-tune a model specifically to catch
these errors, right? Like that I think
wouldn't be crazy at all. Um so yeah, we
wanted kind of that optionality and at
this point you know it's still early
enough right again it's running it's out
there like you know we're still tuning
it. Um, if we get to a point where we're
like, look, the only issue with this is
how much it costs or like specific
details about like how good it is at
catching errors, um, we'd we'd go harder
at that. But we're pretty we're pretty
happy with the balance of it usually
escalates situations that need review,
right? It will sometimes screw up
something just because it thinks that it
was easy and it wasn't. That that does
happen. The same thing happens with
humans, right? So like we we sort of are
meeting the bar that we'd set for
ourselves in the first place. That's a
good distinction though. The evaluator
has a different task of sorts. It does.
It's not really the same thing two
times. Correct. The evaluator is looking
at it differently and it has this
explicit and so one thing actually
though is that the evaluator can see
what the VA is supposed to do, right? It
can see the guidelines. So it can it is
able to basically say you didn't do that
right because I know what you were told
to do and you didn't do it. And likewise
the the virtual OA can see the
evaluator's confidence framework and it
can say well I'm going to be scored
against these things. You know I better
get it right. Again this is very much
more art than science but but I mean
you're asking the right question about
like could we just have either a more
optimal or a cheaper way of doing it. I
think the answer is yes. Okay, let me
keep going for a second. Please just
hold your thoughts. Um, so again, this
idea of like every interaction looks
like this. It is a starting state, a
conversation, an ending state, which
then goes back to the system. And so I
wanted to show you here was if I go back
to a conversation, right? In fact, let
me just see what I got here. Oh, yeah.
In fact, this this answered. So I said
the pregnancy symptoms have decreased.
The next question in the blueprint is do
you think you're done? Right? you know,
do you believe that, you know, the
miscarriage and sort of the the changes
that these medicines were supposed to
elicit have have completed, right? Um,
and there's basically one more message
after this which kind of confirms and
says like, hey, let us know if you have
any questions. But that kind of
interaction, right, back and forth, back
and forth, assessing the state as it
currently exists is what this is built
to do. And we're compressing after every
one of these interactions into only the
changes that happen to the state in a
given time. Right? We're not saving, you
know, in Langmith, we're saving the
entire conversation, right? This data,
sorry, that's the wrong tab. this data,
you know, about like what the virtual
lawyer and the evaluator said to each
other and what tools they called. This
is preserved in Langsmith. We don't get
rid of this, right? But we do not save
this in the state on the blue box,
right? We that's not part of the
patient's interactions with us and we
don't reload it every time you go back
with with a new message because that
would ultimately both confuse things and
and blow up the context window. So
that's the way we've uh we've chosen to
do it. Um so let me let me now show you
this. Um, I have another conversation
here which actually needs response. So,
I'm going to grab this and put it in the
sandbox so you can see what this looks
like. Sorry.
I just got
persistence.
Uh, sorry. Persistence if you only have
what?
You you just don't save the the process
of the model talking to itself, right?
You you have it. You can refer to it if
you need to. It's a debugging tool. Yep.
Yep. input and output is all that we
snapshot in the in the larger system.
Okay. So now let's look at this. So I
think that's actually the wrong one. Let
me go
sorry. Find this again.
All right. Yep. So this this right here
actually, you know, I can I can I don't
have to go to the sandbox to look at
this. This is an example of what happens
when things are complicated enough that
we're asking for human review. Okay. So
in this case, I've just started this
conversation. All right. And I said,
"Yep, I got my medicine came from the
clinic. Here's my time." Now, this is a
moment where in the treatment a lot of
stuff is happening. I'm figuring out
what time zone they're in, right? And
I'm saving that as part of the patient
data, right? So, in this case, I said I
was on West Coast time. So, my time zone
offset is 420 minutes before UTC. Um, I
am going to a new phase of the
treatment. I have my medicine. You know,
now I'm not in onboarding anymore. I'm
actually taking the medicine and I'm
sending multiple messages. So, in the
confidence framework, and I think I can
find this, but uh I won't dig into it
until we get there. Um, in the
confidence framework, we say when you
have all of these changes at once, you
should deduct from your confidence
score. So, you see up here, this
confidence of 70%. I have the threshold
set at 75. So, for anything that's below
75%. I stop and I ask a human to either
approve, right? So, if I were to approve
this, it would just say, "All right,
these changes are fine." And in this
case, the changes are fine. Um, or I
could give feedback, right? I could say,
and I'll try this now, and live demos be
damned. Um, let's say, you know, I want
to say, please mention the patient's
name in your
in your next me in in your messages
or in your message. So, I'll say submit
feedback. Okay. And I'm working through
about this because it's kind of an
operational detail. Um, this is now
going and thinking again. So, I'll have
to reload this in a minute and and see
what happened. But what's actually
happening here if I go over to Langsmith
again, which I should be able to do
is see that what's happening now is that
it is restarting a thread that I already
started in progress. So the one
exception to us wiping out its brain and
reloading everything is when you come
back with this feedback, right? Because
you wanted to basically be able to pick
up right in thread and say, "Hey, you
just did that wrong, but everything else
here, like you need to be able to see
how you got to that place, right?" You
know, so make the right decision and and
finish it up. Um, and so I think
let's find out here.
All right, still thinking. Um, oh, there
we go. So, you can see the only change
that happened here is that it mentioned
her name, right? Otherwise is the same
thing. Same time zone offset, same
treatment phase, same reminder. Um, you
can see the rationale here. Um, and and
you can see here the rationale even
includes this. I changed it to update
the name. Now, you could imagine doing a
version of this where I just had a
little edit box and I said, "I'm going
to change this message." We chose not to
do that, right? We want the LM actually
to drive these changes. We think that
it's better for humans to speak to them
as though they're talking to a person.
Um, this is a debatable choice, but it
is a choice that we made. Um, and part
of that means we can be very very
flexible about the treatment, right? We
can just give feedback on the situation
rather than having to build some sort of
tools that are are are flexible enough
to deal with all different types of
treatments. Um, but so here I'm just
going to go ahead and say approve. And
now those messages go out and the
changes are made, right? I have, you
know, my patient local time set and I
know I'm in the next part of the
blueprint. Okay, I'm going to pause
here. I'm about to jump over to code. I
think we have something like 45 minutes
left. Um, any questions on any of this
so far that are not? I just want to see
the code because I can do that part over
there. Have you heard any
customers?
Yes. Uh, question is about feedback from
patients and that it is emotional. So
yes, absolutely. So remember this is a
system the patient or the client is
already running, right? So fundamentally
they already believe that they're
talking to humans even when they're not
exactly right. Even the humans pushing
the buttons are just calling up
essentially bot generated responses. Um
when things get emotional, um humans can
step in. You know, we we tend to steer
them towards kind of approved knowledge
based responses. Like you don't want
this to be something where it goes
completely free form. There's there's
legal and other reasons not to do that.
So by stepping in and having LM make the
decisions doesn't really change the kind
of current context of these treatments.
They're already getting you know
basically this sort of medically
approved feedback you know based on a
certain flowchart and if it goes
somewhere you know a little crazy the
escalation point is usually to call
someone right it's not you know we keep
on talking forever in text because
that's messy. Um there are a bunch of
points which I'm not going to be able to
demo here which basically just say yeah
I'm sorry I can't answer that question.
call 911, go to your doctor, whatever it
is, right? But that that is usually
where it goes from there.
The blueprints look a lot like
that. Well, it's a great question. So,
honestly, part of it is just that we
needed to have something that the
patient or not the patients, the client
was actually comfortable maintaining,
right? Because remember, part of it is
that we do not want this in code, right?
We don't want this to be something where
you can only maintain it if you have a
technical person. That's the problem
they had before, right? And so just to
jump over for a second, I'll show you
what this was kind of looks like. So
this is essentially the thing that the
client is maintaining. And I'll blow
this up a little bit. I realize that is
small. Um, but the idea here is that
we're using terms and and you know, we
we'll see a bit more of this in the
code. We're using terms that are defined
in the framework. A trigger is you know,
something that happens, you know,
essentially after an event, right? Um,
you know, we have the the conversation
of these messages. We always tell the LM
why this is important. If we just had
this this detail and we just said this
is the message you send, I don't think
it would perform as well. It's much more
helpful to actually give the LLM
justification for why it would say
something because then it makes better
decisions. Um, one of the many quirks.
Um, go ahead. on that. I'm not sure if
this is code or not for the next part,
but how how complicated how simple
statements
or if you have any any actually got lost
in the Oh, sure. Yep. So, so the
question was just about you know
essentially why why do we have this
framework and and why is it maybe not
more declarative, right? In terms of
like specifically if then and that sort
of thing, right? Actually I I use
similar with with a different index and
like I got indus
so I couldn't go like very complicated
not a lot of nested got to be like one
two levels
right my question
so I I the so the answer is just about
again how do you how do you define these
things as clearly but you know maybe not
complexely as as possible. Right? So, um
this this framework tends to work where
you're really just saying, look, I'm
giving you this approved language and
I'm trying to give you in the bold
statements here, right? Primarily, I'm
trying to give you a sense of, you know,
what what the conditioning really is.
But part of the reason that we did it
this way is because, you know, if the
patient writes back after this thing and
he says, you know, yes, I have the
medication and I took the pills and my
stomach hurts and I'm confused, right? I
mean, it could be all these things. We
wouldn't want to represent something
like that in a flowchart. What we really
want to do is just say, "Look, this is
the outline of the thing. You can see
it. You know, if you need to jump ahead,
jump ahead and don't ask the patient
questions they've already answered." It
just turns out that this this framework
really does work pretty well for letting
the LM do that sort of thing. It's I
know that's kind of a magic answer, but
pretty good at it.
Uh yeah. No, I mean Claude Yeah, Claude
mostly nails it. Most of them do. Yes.
Does including the instructions
response quality? Uh, sorry. What do you
mean by including the instructions?
Including the reasoning. Oh, the
reasoning. I I So, question was do does
including the reasoning help with the
response quality? I think it does,
right? I mean, this is one of these
things where we started also by
borrowing from human documentation,
right? So, this was a process that was
originally explained to humans who were
going to push the buttons. And so we
took a combination of flowcharts that
existed to explain the flow of the
treatment and these kinds of you know
this is the message that you should send
in these situations and and this was
kind of the the hybrid output of those
two things. So I wouldn't say we did
aggressive testing on is it is it really
better or is it just that you know this
is good enough. It's more that like we
started with this framework based on the
human materials we had. A follow
question to that. Yeah. Did you find any
sacrifices that you had to make
as
form.
Yeah. So question is uh maintaining this
document as human readable versus LM.
Yes, there are trade-offs. I think
they're still worth it. We we may change
our mind at some point, right? So, you
know, imagine the workflow here being um
you know, this this Google doc is
maintained essentially by our
physician's assistant, right? She is the
co-owner of the blueprint maybe next to
me. Um when we when we make changes, we
talk about them together. We recommend
in this document and then accept them.
and then effectively I I export it to
markdown and check it in. Right? That is
going to change a little bit. We're
going to build a lot of these tools into
the database and so that that's really
where you'd be doing this instead. Um
but because this is human, you know,
maintained, right? Because it is
basically, you know, still driven by the
team. Um yes, we we are making a
trade-off. I don't think it's a
trade-off that's that's super damaging.
Based on your current design, yeah, just
now when you do the thing,
what does change after is it like a one
time or does it improve your answer in
the future or even changing the
so at the moment? No. And the question
was just about uh the approve uh sort of
defer um you know feedback mechanism. Um
so actually I'll go back and just show
this really quick. This should be done
now. Um there we go. Um again we are we
are saving this in the sense that I can
see this in lang right. I can look at
this and I can say well in you know
these cases where an approval was needed
and in this case like just just as a a
visual you know sort of feedback
whenever you have this graph null start
right that that is one of these cases
where you know there was an approve
feedback defer choice um I could filter
by this and I could look at all of these
things and I could say well what kinds
of things were we actually trying to
approve or give feedback on um we don't
learn from them right we we as humans
will maybe update the blueprints we do
not put this back into training data
again for a bunch of reasons which are
are kind of specific to the situation um
but you So you can see here that like I
can go all the way down here and I'll
try to find this quickly. Um and you'll
get to a point where the human says all
right yeah here it is. So we get
feedback from yeah from the humano. This
is essentially what happens whenever I
push that button and I say give feedback
right the humano has feedback about your
unscent messages. The feedback is
mention their name. Um it just goes
right back to business. It's like okay
let me look at the messages that you
know I was sending. I'm going to update
with this one. I'm gonna probably delete
not sure actually no it just updated
that one in place we rescored it one
thing we've said is that we do not
change the confidence score on something
that a human reviewed we leave it where
it was right we let them review it again
right and so in all these cases this
this is also a much quicker you know
simpler sort of operation right and so
you can see the evaluator here is
basically like yep that message is fine
but we're not going to do anything you
know really to change the the overall
score um so you know that's the kind of
thing that you know we can look at
afterwards Right. But we are not at this
point at least, you know, really trying
to feed that back into the model. It's
really just for the blueprints.
Just get a sense of your metrics. Um, a
lot of these are, you know, over a
minute and it says about a couple
hundred thousand. How do you kind of
look like a necessary evil? The time it
takes, the cost.
No, no. I mean, it it is a necessary
evil and and actually just to point it
out, um, these costs I don't believe are
correct. Um, one of one of the
shortcomings of Langmith and I think
they've admitted this in various forms
is they don't really take into account
the caching. Um, so these costs should
be lower than what you see here. Um, but
but fundamentally, yeah, these are
expensive operations and you know we
could change we could change some of
them at the potential cost of higher
error rates, right? Like we could try to
cache more and have you inherit threads
in progress and it would be faster,
right? Because you've already loaded
everything. it would be, you know,
potentially you're not reloading any
context and so, you know, you're you're
spending maybe less on tokens and you
just might have a higher error rate and
and that's, you know, a thing we are
trading off.
Is there some kind of knowledge base
that your model is taking to
depending on the medicine?
Uh yeah. So the question is just uh in
terms of the the knowledge basis. So let
me let me actually jump over and just
show this really quick. So I mentioned
these blueprints. Um I I'll jump over
now really into just what the the the
implementation looks like. So you can
see over here, you know, this idea of
for a VA, right? We have a handful of
documents here that are again exported
into Markdown. Um and I'll try to blow
this up because I know these are small.
Um let me just shrink this down. Okay,
so the idea here is that you know I've
got all of this, you know, uh sort of
framework data, right? The idea of
defining what do I mean by a blueprint,
right? We're doing we're we're defining
this every time not in um the the
prompt, right? We're doing this as part
of the context window in part because we
do want this to be really flexible. If
you want to change the terms um you
should be able to do that, right? We
don't want the treatments to be
hamstrung by by terms we use for other
treatments. I define anchors. I talk
about schedules. I talk about scheduled
messages, right? So all of this stuff
exists in part just to to lay the
groundwork. And then this framework,
right, is now referring to specific
documents, right? And so you can see
here like I again these documents are
all referring to each other. So I can go
through here and I can look you know and
and click on these links and go straight
to other things if I want to do
something around the knowledge base. So
the way that we do that is this triage
idea. Um so you know if something
happens that a blueprint doesn't address
right. So the way that we tar it is
first check on the blueprint. If you
have approved language use it right send
it send it back for human review
whatever you need to do right but use
that approved language. If you don't
think you can answer that question you
go and look at this which now again is
is self-referential. We don't read the
entire scope of medically approved
knowledge all at once. We let the Ellen
decide are they complaining about
stomach pain or bleeding, right? You
know, if I can't find anything in any
one of these, I have a larger knowledge
base, right? Which is, you know, sort of
just a laundry list of like random
questions people ask. Um, we've chosen
to do it this way in part because it is
human readable. It mirrors something the
client already mostly had, right? They
already had a lot of these structures.
Um, and you know, we fundamentally did
not believe that it made sense to
overprocess, you know, things like a
rag. Now I will say that for the thing
that we have like kind of a backup you
know sort of knowledge store which is
almost entirely a CSV that probably is
suited for rag right it would be okay to
use a rag for that it doesn't get used
that much right so in some sense it's
just not worth implementing that way at
least not yet
all right um yeah
yep
that is prompt level. So we the the
virtual OA and the and the evaluator
both have relatively small prompts which
I can show. So let me just see if I can
find them here. Um those prompts are are
they do reference each other right? So
imagine this being um you know again
built on the line chain stuff. So the
base agent class um this prompt is
basically aware of the other agent,
right? So in this case it's just two. So
the prompts do speak about each other.
The evaluator knows about the virtual
away and vice versa, right? You know the
things that we try to do and you know
this is I think normal prompt
engineering stuff for people who have
really played with this stuff. You have
to tell it how to take turns. You have
to tell it that it you know if it gets
called on it has to talk, right? Like
you know one one problem we have that we
have to sort of frequently do retries on
is the LM thinks that everything's done.
It doesn't say anything and and the
whole thing dies. Um so you know you
have to talk but then you can be done,
right? You just have to say something.
um we have the basic idea of you have to
determine this overall confidence score
but we don't include this in the prompt
because we want to be able to show it to
the virtual OA as well right so the
details of how you score something is is
is factored out but the notion of here's
who you are here's this other guy is and
here's how you work together that is in
the prompts
okay actually on that note let me jump
over and actually show you some of the
the confidence stuff and the the
guidelines so um I'll start with
confidence I'll get into the guidelines
which are much much longer This again is
you know intended to be mostly LLM
readable. This is not something the
client generally maintains, right? So
this is not in the same category as
these blueprints. But the idea here is
that you know I've got this confidence
score and you know I am trying to figure
out across these multiple dimensions. Do
I know what's going on? You know here
are some examples. We we are trying to
be as prescriptive as possible with
examples of these different situations.
Um do I know you know the knowledge that
I need to know? Here's an example which
might speak to your question actually
over here. you know, the idea of do we
want the LM to use its world knowledge
to figure out that when I'm talking
about an antibiotic and I give a
specific antibiotic that it applies to
the whole class of them. Yes, that
that's a risk that we're kind of willing
to take, right? We don't need to have an
explicit this specific antibiotic is
safe for this treatment, right? That
would very quickly spiral out of
control. So, we do have a handful of
places where we ask it. Use your own
judgment, but refer to, you know, the
the knowledge base and the blueprints
for for your baseline. Um and then so
after I get through these categories
then I have this idea of deductions
right and the deductions here um are
specifically things like you know you
should deduct from the overall score not
the individual messages right because an
individual message could be like yeah
this is exactly from the blueprint like
it's the right thing to say but overall
these situations can be complicated
right and so what we're trying to do is
explain that such that it can again
score the overall interaction in a way
that surfaces it for for human review
um okay so I'm going to move on to the
guidelines because again there's just a
lot more in here. Um, this is long
enough that I'm not going to review
everything, but I'll try to get to some
of the biggest parts. Again, some of
this is really simple, right? Like tool
calling. Um, one issue we've certainly
had over time is, you know, fabrication
and and, you know, honestly,
instructions like this do help. Um, you
know, do not make up a tool call. Wait,
wait your turn, right? Call the tool and
step back. Um, there's a lot of stuff
around time, right? There is a lot of
stuff around, hey, you need to ask about
it in the right way. You don't ask about
it in a way that forces someone to tell
you where they are. Right? there. People
are very sensitive about this. They
don't want, you know, people knowing
where they physically are, but you need
to know what their time is so that you
can schedule the messages for them,
right? Um, you want, you know, when you
work with time, um, you have to use
things like, you know, ISO time stamps,
like that's how the rest of the system
works. Um, but calculating these things
and keeping them all straight, it
requires a relatively smart model. So, a
lot of this, you know, has has sort of
grown over time to just work with the
idea that, you know, this is how you can
talk to models about this and do a
pretty good job um, setting anchors,
scheduling messages. Again, these are
all the things that are core parts of
the system. This is not treatment
specific, right? This is all written to
be generic enough that I don't have to
rewrite this every time I add a new
drug, right? Which which is one of the
core requirements, right? We did not
want to have to do this in code. Yes.
So, this is a very big document.
Yep. Uh have you experimented with the
caching because this doesn't change.
Yeah, correct. No, we have. And so,
right now, and I'll get to caching
actually in just a second. I'm just
trying to manage time here, but I do
have time for that. like we are we are
doing some explicit system prompt
caching and then we are caching
explicitly um you know the the multiple
turns of the messages such that you know
each operation is you know I think the
average operation with just sort of the
baseline stuff is maybe 10 to 15,000
tokens right per turn all cached it adds
up right so you know you do have maybe
the average cost to generate a single
message somewhere in the 15 to 20 cent
range right it it's not cheap but we are
caching as aggressively as we can we
have thought about things all this is
brand new right the idea of the of the
hour cache, you know, that that Claude
just introduced. It's not clear to us
that that would help because, you know,
we can't guarantee that the patient's
going to get back to us within, you
know, either five minutes or an hour,
right? It's just it's a bit of a risk to
take at the system level. Um, but if
anybody here actually knows more about
cloud caching than I do, please talk to
me because like we we ideally we would
like to cache a lot of these documents.
Um, it's just not clear if we can do
that across sessions. It's not clear if
you know we would get the benefits that
we're looking for. So, we've just tried
to be as aggressive as we can within a
single conversation.
That's a very long list of guidelines.
How did you come up with it and how do
you optimize?
Yeah, I mean the look the the real
answer is that I mentioned before that
you know there's a few thousand lines of
code and a few thousand lines of prompt.
This is most of that prompt, right? I
mean this is a lot of it. Um it is
something where you know we have tuned
it over time. This is you know myself as
well as you know the the the physician
assistant like we have come up with
something that we believe is
fundamentally you know pretty good at
handling these you know generic
situations and when we find edge cases
we we just modify these prompts. It
again it is not perfect. We could
definitely think about subdividing this.
We could think about moving some of it
into the prompts. Um but we think this
division is you know roughly correct for
keeping it generic so that it's you know
it handles a bunch of different
treatments and it it handles the
situations that we see across treatments
pretty well. Right. You will have cases
where you're doing medicine that's all
in one day. That that's relatively
unusual because you know that's
something you just send instructions
home. Um you know but there I mean I'll
show an example around ampic you know
that's weekly monthly right like there's
there's much longer durations. We've
tried to get to a point of balancing it
where you know we we do end up with a
good result.
Okay. Uh yeah back there.
Yeah.
Yeah. So question is just about the
prompt length. Um so again not not to
dismiss that out of hand in claude terms
this isn't actually that long right. I
mean this is like I said I think on
average 15,000 tokens. Um it still
leaves a lot of the window you know
behind right. it is it is not actually
so long that we start seeing really
crazy behaviors until we start doing
multiple turns like multiple
conversations in one thread right that's
where it starts to blow up um so we we
just genuinely have not gotten to a
point where we're like my guidelines are
too long you know the guidelines could
be a little shorter and I think we we
have optimized them in various places
over time but you know we've we've
crammed this into a box where we really
can sort of process one situation all in
one gulp without really feeling any any
pain.
Okay. Yeah. Any examples on tools that
you have? You mentioned tools. I'm not
sure. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, no. So, I I can I
can share a little bit of that. So, let
me uh let me go down here to the tools
code itself. So, so one thing to note,
this is a hybrid and I think I mentioned
this really earlier on about um there is
some stuff coming from an MCP gateway,
right? So, in this case, you know, I'm
loading from files. It's just the file
system MCP. Again, all localized to our
VPC. So, there's nothing crazy going on
there. Um but I could instead load from,
you know, my database, right? I could
choose to to have that be the place
where we interact. There's a bunch of
other tools, right? And so, you know,
this this actually is where probably
most of the code in my app actually is.
Um, the list of tools is essentially
down here. And you can see it's things
that enable interacting with the state,
right? So, all of these functions that
are looking at anchors and messages and
confidence and the treatment and patient
data, all of that stuff is local to my
graph run. I don't have an MCP for it. I
could, I just chose not to. Um, and you
know, in this case, like this code just
lives in this Python app. You could you
could very much refactor this out. Like
the state can still live here and the
code could be somewhere else. It's it's
you know, it's up to you. Um, but one
note actually about all of this stuff is
I'm trying to find a good example here.
So I am aggressively using the command
object. Um, for anybody who who has
programmed with Langraph, the whole idea
behind this is that at any given point
you're able to pass back a message and
this particular thing is just an error
message, but like you know you're able
to pass back a message and a place to
go, right? So you can say here's the
here's the response and by the way I
know that the evaluator asked for this
so go back to the evaluator. You can
actually get around some of the graph
routing um this way. And so we we've
we've definitely you know tried to work
this into both the MCP tools and the
state tools that we have. Yeah.
Yeah. Uh so question was about how to
how do we improve the prompt? So, um it
was really a fusion of um we were able
to go from essentially the physician's
assistant who had the most experience
with tricking things, right? Was coming
up with tricky situations, right? So, we
were able to test a lot of the edges
really just with her, you know, having
her pretend to be the patient. We then
scaled up to the full team of operations
associates who, you know, then tried to
trick it at a higher level, right? And,
you know, were putting out things that
they'd seen from patients themselves,
you know, trying to sort of um you know,
get to these complicated cases. Um, and
then, you know, with real people, you
know, we're able to take that a step
further. Um, but with those first two
levels, we're we're not seeing, you
know, a tremendous amount of stuff
that's not expected. Again, this system
exists. If we'd been doing this from
absolute scratch, I think we would have
a lot tougher of a time coming up with
what we think the edges are. Whereas,
you know, this is a system that already
exists. There's a lot of conversations
to draw from. We're able to run some of
those back. So, we'll look at at
conversations in the old system and
replay them here and essentially just
try to figure out, you know, where the
edges are.
Is there
you state.
Sure. So, is there a question about are
the questions about um how to decide
what goes in the state or not? Um
I mean the I guess the short answer is
everything that comes in in that initial
payload which I'll go back over here
for. Um all of this stuff I think this
one's probably the better example. Yeah.
So all of this stuff over here this is
all state. um there's not really a
distinction like everything that comes
in to sort of preload the conversation
is state some of it is editable um some
of it's not I'm trying to remember
examples like here examples are you
can't change the source I couldn't say
you know in the context of the LM
operation this is not an ail patient
anymore right that's the LM is not
allowed to do that um it also can't
change past messages so the LM is not
allowed to look at the message queue and
say message five that went out three
days ago no longer exists like that
function doesn't exist um so we've sort
of just calibrated to where the only
things it can do is read the entire
state, modify the patient data, modify
messages, modify anchors like like
unscent messages. So it's, you know,
it's just a software choice like that's
how we architected it.
If you have a session
that went back
window
summarize it. Yeah. Yeah.
Sure. I mean I I think the I think the
real answer though is that hasn't
happened for us. like the way that we've
structured it. There is not a single
thinking operation that that goes long
enough to blow things up. Um but but I
will talk really quickly about um
retries. So we do have the notion and
I'll just pop this up maybe just an
easier way to see it. Um so we do have
the notion inside the graph of you know
again the virtual OA talks to the
evaluator you know at at a certain a
certain point in the thing everybody
uses tools but then there are cases that
will cause the the graph to retry a
certain operation right so one of them
is um one of the agents malforms a tool
call right it tries to call a tool but
it uses the wrong JSON and you know
otherwise things would have died we can
detect that we delete the message and we
say you screwed up that tool call try
again right that you know keeps it
inside the graph, right? Essentially,
this retry node is then able to loop
back via that um command message. Uh
it's not shown here on the graph, but
via that command object. It can say go
back to the virtual OA, try that again,
right? We also have some cases where
again, you know, we expect the model to
talk and it doesn't, right? There are
just a bunch of cases where Claude will
just end its turn prematurely. We detect
that. We say you have to say something,
right? Like literally, that's the
message is like don't just say nothing.
If even if if you're going to end your
turn, just say I'm done, right? That's
enough, you know, for us to keep the
logic going. So it's things like that.
Low confidence from the evaluator will
be trigger. I'm sorry, say it again. Low
confidence coming from the evaluator.
No, no. So low confidence is something
we want to pass through to the human,
right? So low confidence is a valid
response to the graph, right? You know,
like I have a low confidence message I
want a human to review. That's fine.
Uh yeah, build your system prompt up.
It's long. It's pretty complicated. It's
not the system prompt. No, no, that's
thing. It's that's what that's why we
separated it. So yes, the guidelines
have expanded over time. Yep. Okay.
Yeah. How do you make sure you don't
Yeah. Perfect time to talk about evals.
So we're getting towards the end. Um let
me talk about evals a little bit just to
sort of give you guys a sense of what we
did here. So um this was this was a
weird one because if you go to Langmith
and I'll just I'm not sure I can find
the exact place where this happens. Um
but there's is it under maybe it's under
data sets I I forget. There is a place
in here where you can basically say I
want to run you know an evaluation
against you know these these you know
this this data set that I've defined in
lang. Um I do define data sets in lang.
So I can see here assuming this loads up
which hopefully it will. So I've got a
happy path data set here that I defined
in length. I this isn't the whole thing.
Again some of this is redacted but um if
I look at these things what I'm really
doing is I'm saying okay this is an
interaction that we had in the past. Um,
you know, this was one that I ran last
week. Um, you know, here's, you know,
the the input, right? This is the last
message from the patient. This
conversation, you know, a I've got this
initial state here that I can look at,
right? So, I can see, you know, what was
going on in the first place. Um, I see
this conversation and, you know, I get
to the end and I get a message out which
says, great, you're ready to start.
Okay, so this is one part of my happy
path data set. The eval that I'm running
um are fundamentally it's a it's a
custom harness. I'll blow this up a
little bit. Hopefully, it's visible to
most folks. Um, but again, the idea here
was that we couldn't just say, you know,
when I ask for, you know, what the
weather is in San Francisco, it gives me
back, you know, cold and, you know,
foggy. Um, it had to be here's examples
of these input states and then, you
know, let's evaluate it, you know, sort
of an LLM as a judge form what the
output state looks like with the caveat
that one of the big things we wanted to
test was things like time operations.
So, I can't put in an eval from three
weeks ago and run it now and get
equivalent times. I have to either give
it really specific guidance on how to
handle time or I have to replace all the
time stamps. Um, we ended up sort of
doing a hybrid of both. Um, and so what
this did was my eval suite is a custom
Python app stapled to a bash script.
This was all client coded. Um, I I got
what I wanted, but I can't vouch for
much more than that. Um, I load data
sets right from Langmith. I call
essentially the medical agent via in
this case like I'm running this locally
like I could run this against my cloud
Lang graph instance but I'm literally
running this against Lang graph on my
laptop using that data set from
Langsmith having pre-processed a bunch
of stuff around dates times you know
sort of circumstances so that when I get
back the result I can not confuse the LM
as a judge about whether it's right or
not. Um and I'm using this LLM rubric
right to do this. And so let me see if I
can find my rubric here. So well here's
here's a couple examples. So I've got
this this YAML. So this is just this is
prompt fu and how it works. Um what I do
is I basically say look I'm trying to
test you know this this custom thing
that I'm going to call you know
essentially with with my um you know my
my custom harness and then I want you to
evaluate it you know with an LLM and in
this case I think it's using GPT40. Um
you know this the valuation rubric is
basically is everything basically
exactly the same? Do I see minor
discrepancies but I don't think they're
a big deal. I mean we're we're keeping
this very fuzzy. What we really want to
know is is anything completely busted,
right? And then there are cases where it
is. Um I had to put in specific notes
here like hey don't be picky about like
the you know different wording that you
might see in something like an anchor
right sometimes it'll say they will take
the medicine it says they did take the
medicine like who cares like in this
case the spirit of it was right. Um and
so you know and then times and dates
like there's some specific language
here. So all of this turns into
basically this guy right here. So, um,
when I look at this, and again, I
realize there's a lot of text here. Um,
it's not worth looking at all of it. I
ran these three examples from my data
set and I got, you know, basically a
passing grade, right? I'll I'll go into
the fail, one fail, one pass in a
second, but in each of these cases,
right, I can see what the LM as a judge
said, right? So, if I go down here, this
is GPT40
going, you know, opining on, well, this
is the source data you gave me in the
sample output. Here's the run I just
did. Close enough, right? um you know it
does point out some things right so if I
ran these evals and I was like well it's
actually a big problem that you know the
reminder you know unscent message didn't
show up right I I could make a choice to
do that I could I could strengthen my
rubric but the way that we did this was
just to say look at any given point we
do need to be able to test the current
state of the system we want to do it
against you know first the happy path
and then we can certainly do it against
edge cases um we're actively maintaining
this I think this might change once we
actually hand this over you know more
fully to the client right we want them
to have all the protection they might
need but it's this style right this
style of email. Does that answer your
question? More or less. Okay.
Okay. Um, yes. Go ahead.
Yeah. So, I mean, the short answer is
yes. Some of that I'm redacting for for
a couple reasons, but yeah, more or less
we we started with a happy path. We do
have a handful of of specific like, hey,
this is busted and it's frequently
busted. Let's make sure it's not um you
know that, but it's just a different
data set. Yeah. Uh yeah.
Well, so again, the the part that I'm
showing here is entirely Python in a
line graph container. Um I would guess
it's, you know, maybe 4,000 lines of
code. Um most of it is honestly the tool
calls like that that just and I I'm sure
I could refactor that to be shorter
also. Um it's not much. It's really just
enough to run essentially this graph,
right? You know, I have to have the
routing between all of it. I have to
have the tools that it can call. Um
everything else is in the prompts and
the guidelines, right? And so, you know,
it really is more English than it is
code. On the other side, right, on the
other side of the box, right, this
thing, um that blue box is I don't know
exactly how much code, but it's entirely
um Node and React and and Um and
and frankly, I haven't been that
involved in it. Sorry. Yep. I also
industry.
Yeah.
How do you think about this one?
Yeah. Great question. So, uh, questions
about scale. So, let me actually jump
over and show you one thing I should
have probably already shown, but I I
forgot. I mentioned before the idea of
us doing different treatments. So, um,
what I did in in in this particular
case, so you know, again, we were
focused on on the the early pregnancy
loss. Um, I did this, in fact, I think I
have this sitting here somewhere. So,
let me zoom out and find it and then
I'll zoom back in. So, I took this to
Klein and I basically said to Klein,
"Hey, I've got Yeah, this should be it
right here." Um, I said, "I'm looking to
make a new treatment, right? I defined
one for Aila. Here's the structure,
right? Have a look. Um, here's the link
to, you know, Noon Nordisk's suggestions
on how to dose Osmpic. Um, make me
something new, right? Um, and it
basically went through this process, and
I'll I'll shrink this down. Um, and
created, you know, a basic treatment,
you know, for Osmpic. It read these
files. It then decided, all right, I got
it. Here's the thing I'm going to do.
Um, I just said, cool, go for it. And
here's a couple of tweaks based on the
thing that you said. So, I, again, this
is my client process. I use this all the
time. Um, and I ended up with what I
think is a pretty serviceable treatment,
which I will very quickly show you here.
If I go back to these conversations, I'm
pretty sure I named these people all O.
So, there you go. Here's Oliver with
Osmpic. Um, and you can see it's still
Ava. I didn't change that, right? I I I
you could obviously get to the point of
having it be a different personality,
but in this case, this is Ava with a new
treatment asking all about Ozmpic pens
and helping me figure out their time.
Same as we were before. It's a weekly
injection. I didn't change any code for
this. I literally threw this through
client got a new set of treatments out
and it just kind of works. Yes. Yeah. In
your graph
that for it's for catching uh the retry
node. The question was um it's for
catching those errors around um
malforming tool calls is one easy way
for the graph to terminate. Right? So if
it you know forgets a bracket and you
know sends back something that's invalid
JSON. Um Claude does this a lot less
now. Like Sonnet 4 is pretty good at it
but um Sonnet 3.5 was not nearly as
good. So, we can detect that and we can
just say, well, you're trying to make a
tool call because I see certain things
in here. I either see tool call ID as a
parameter. I see weird brackets, you
know, we can parse that in code. Um, and
then again, we wipe that message out and
we go back to the guy that called it and
said, "Hey, you up, pardon my
French." Um, you know, try again. And
so, that idea of, you know, the retry
node, there's a handful of those
situations where we aren't going to take
over and do it in some deterministic
way. We're just telling the LM, you made
a mistake. Here's the character of your
mistake. Try again. And we do have to
wipe out its memory of that mistake
because it can get very confused. Like
one of the reason, one of the ways this
happened a lot earlier in our testing
was it would malform tool calls and then
hallucinate the results, right? And so
if you left the message in there, it
would think that it understood the
blueprint even though it had made the
entire blueprint up, right? So I don't
want to sugarcoat where like there are
some weird cases that if you don't very
carefully control for it, you can end up
with some very bad behaviors. But we
were able to catch the main ones and
essentially just give it another shot. I
was looking for like a loop. Oh, all
right. Sorry. The reason there's no loop
this this is just totally this is
actually one thing where I think
Langmith and Lang graph could be better
at this. The retry node is capable of
calling back to the other ones using the
command object but it doesn't show up on
the graph. So it turns out like they
were very invested Langmith was or Lang
graph in graph flows and then they
introduced this idea of well you don't
even really have to define it in the
graph you can send anything anywhere and
so that's what we're using.
Yeah.
No, sure. But remember, sorry, the
question was about confidence scoring
and how do we get it to sort of to be
higher. Um, we want the score to be
lower when there is a complicated
situation, not because we think it's
wrong, but because we want a human to
review it.
Um, well, so sorry, what do you mean?
Correct. Yes.
So if if the confidence score is above
the threshold, meaning higher than it,
right? So let's say I have a confidence
score of 0.9. What that could mean,
right, is that I am sending multiple
messages at a time, but there's no other
reason for me to think that those
messages are wrong. Um, we have chosen
with the client to set the threshold
lower than that because they don't want
their humans having to get involved
every single time something is a little
complicated. But we've agreed that if
it's below 0 75, they should. It's
purely just a calibration, right? It's
you you decide if you wanted your humans
involved in everything, set the
conference score to 100, right? You
could see every single thing that
happens. You're just clicking approve
all day. You're George Jetson. But um
that's hopefully not what people
actually want, right? You want a bunch
of these things if they are high
confidence and you know, fundamentally
recoverable, let's say. Like, you know,
there might be certain circumstances
where you don't want a message
automatically sent out. Hopefully, we
can control for that. But in general
like we wanted to set it in a place that
felt like we were going to get some
scale out of our humans, right? Which
meant messages going out automatically,
right? Uh yes.
Yeah. trying to evaluate
whe
Yeah.
Yeah. So the question is about
conflation of of confidence scoring and
complexity. Yes. 100% agree. And again
it's one of the things where I think
we're happy with how it sort of operates
now but I'm not sure that we're doing
the confidence piece right. Um and at
the same time like the concept of it I
think is is good right? You know do you
have the information you need? you know,
is is there anything like do you
understand the user's intent or you
know, did they say something ambiguous?
And we do see cases where it triggers,
right? It's not that we never see it,
you know, correctly rate itself as being
like, well, I'm not totally sure what
they said, but it's not as frequent as
we would like. So, we combine it with
complexity in part because, you know, we
just want to get it below that threshold
so that we can have a human review it.
It's not a perfect system, but it is a
system that we think works. So it's more
confidence.
Correct.
Uh correct. So to to that point, it's
it's not confidence that the specific
response is exact and perfect and
whatever it is, it's confidence that we
don't think that there's a blend of
uncertainty on, you know, what the
response is and complexity of the
situation, right? Either of those things
can push it below the threshold.
How are you hosting?
Uh so this is all uh the question was
about hosting. So this is all um
Langraph has a pre-built
containerization that you can use. We
are using it with a couple of
modifications. Um we are essentially
deploying both halves of this right so
to go back to this we're deploying both
halves of this with Terraform. You know
everything's hooked up with GitHub
actions. I mean like you know we're
we're doing as much of as automatically
as we can but we are using most of the
built-in line graph containerization. I
thought there was a
platform
you do know I mean we're we we have a
conversation with with Langchain
actively about that. So the question
actually is also um the the specific
nature of how we need to be deployed. Um
Langraph platform doesn't currently
support that right. So like there it's
it's all it's all evolving but um we we
have had those conversations Um, let me
pause for a second. We still have 10
minutes. Um, and so, or roughly 10
minutes, nine minutes. Um, let me just
double check my own list of things that
I wanted to talk about just to make sure
I didn't miss anything major. Um, talked
about that, talked about that.
All right. I I think we more or less hit
everything. Um, and and so I'm happy
just to open it up. Um, I have a couple
of final thoughts that I'll leave
sitting up here um if anyone's curious.
Um, any other questions?
Yep.
Yeah. Uh so the question was just about
uh resource allocation to build these
things. So I mean I think the best way
to say it is just that we had built a
handful of things like this. We had not
done it for healthcare, right? But we
were able to bring some things in in
terms of you know I had an open source
Langraph project that I was comfortable
using as a base for for this client code
right again we we forked it we brought
it in private um you know but it got us
you know part of the way there in in
part because this isn't a totally
special snowflake it's it's a workflow
with tools so you know we have I think
spent less time on that upfront
scaffolding each time we've done it um
and you know we're looking at another
project right now which would be that
much quicker so a lot of it is just once
you do this and you understand the
mechanism getting to you know good
enough or getting to a starting point is
just a lot quicker. Um, it is something
though where like you know again we we
are we are still working on this and
we've been at it for a few months but I
think we probably built what would have
been a year's worth of conventional
software maybe more right you know in
that short period of time
anything else yeah so you mentioned you
did a lot of coding this can a little
bit I'm curious how much
lang
like
well okay so so the uh the question was
is about uh vibe coding and how much the
tools know of these frameworks. So the
single biggest issue with vibe coding,
right, is when you're dealing with
something new enough that the models
don't really understand it. Um you can
always just send them the API docs and
they usually do pretty well. Um I ran
into plenty of places with Langraph
where nobody had tried to do this
before, no one had this exact bug and we
just had to actively debug it back and
forth. Um I can definitely endorse 03 is
a better debugger than Claude. Um so you
know we we did have cases where we had
to do that. Um, but for the most part,
like I mean, as long as you can at the
docks, you know, you you can get to a
reasonable place. And again, like I am a
former engineer. I I may eventually call
myself a current engineer, but I I kind
of wouldn't right now. Like I don't have
all the same practices and sort of all
the same hygiene, you know, that our our
professional engineers do. But I do know
how to smell kind of bad behavior. And
I'm pretty good at prompting to get what
I want. So that that's kind of how it
how it worked out.
Um, any Oh, yeah. Please. In this
example,
No, there is MCP. MCP is is in a couple
places, right? So, if you look at the
connection there, there's actually two
and one of them I just didn't totally
label the blueprint knowledge base at
the top that yellow box that is an MCP
connection in the Langraph context and
then vertically there's another set of
connections back to the database. So,
there's a couple places where it
happens, but again, it's mostly for the
inter the exchange of state and it's for
this, you know, reading of documents.
That's primarily where it happens.
Yep.
Yep. Absolutely.
Yeah.
Yep. So the question is about rapid fire
text messages. So yes, the the way we
handle that is is twofold. So one is
that um we do have a configurable I'm
not totally sure we have this turned on,
but we have the idea of a configurable
delay before we actually send it for
processing. So if someone is going to
send five text messages in a row, we
wait five seconds before doing anything,
right? Um that's one way we can catch
it. But the other way is um we will
invalidate previous running threads if
someone texts in afterwards, right? We
don't want an inprocess response. We
want to take whatever the complete
context of the conversation was, send
all of that in, and then we respond to
five messages at once, right? So it's a
combination of smart retries and smart
invalidation.
Yeah.
Yep.
Well, this question was about rogue
responses.
Well, in general, we are we are giving
some pretty basic guidance around you're
only here to answer treatment related
questions. If someone wants to talk to
you about the weather, you just say,
"I'm sorry. I can't help with that." Um,
you know, or other worse things. Um, so
generally speaking, that works pretty
well. Um, we have it pretty well tuned
to escalate, right? If someone just is
essentially going off the rails and you
can't think of a response, you just say,
"I'm sorry, I'm going to get somebody to
help you." And it sets the confidence
low and then a human can get involved.
Um, it doesn't in practice happen that
much. I mean, again, if you're involved
in this, like, you know, if you're
involved in this and you take the time
to actually engage with the system, you
want the result and you probably want to
get back to your life. So we don't see a
tremendous amount of it but but that's
the way that we would deal with it.
at any point in your development process
you get frustrated enough
uh yeah did did I get frustrated enough
with Lang graph um at any point honestly
so the the one thing I'll say and I this
this is just totally a personal project
um I was doing a side thing um around
college counseling um and I just have
this sitting here because I've showed
off sometimes um and the point was I I
went into this project explicitly trying
to avoid it I said I'm going to do a
very similar thing where I have an AI in
the middle of a workflow and I wanted to
ask questions and I wanted to think and
I do not want to use Lang graph or crew
or any of these other frameworks because
I don't want to be dependent on them. Um
and so I asked you know I asked Klein to
write me a layer that was pretty good at
you know uh talking to these models and
structuring a thinking process and it it
did fine. I mean the reason to have the
framework is in part because you know
again we won't be with this client
forever. We want them to have something
they can operate. we want them to have
something explainable and easy to use
like this is all you know logs in Google
cloud like it's not the most fun
experience so you know it is very much
choose your tools wisely you know good
and bad like you get a better experience
with the other ones speaking on that
uh uh thank you so much for asking me
that question um I I so clin over cursor
um I I will admit that cursor and and
windsurf is great by the way like I mean
there's a handful of them that I really
do like um cursor and windsurf as as two
examples are are are just trying to hit
this sort of narrow um you know thing
about it has to cost $20 a month and
therefore it has to be heavily optimized
about how it sends tokens in different
places otherwise their economics blow
up. Um Klein doesn't do that. It's very
simple. It's really I mean it's very
smart but like it's just giving tools to
a smart model and that smart model can
cost whatever it costs. Klein is the
spiritual cousin to claude code and
codecs, right? I mean it's that style of
thing as opposed to an IDE that has to
hit this very narrow target and has to
do a lot of pre-optimization on how the
the tokens flow. Yeah.
Yeah. So, I mean, honestly, this is also
another place where I will raise my hand
and say this is why I'm not a real
software engineer. I I don't have a
robust testing framework on my Python
code. I I haven't really needed it,
right? Or at the very least, like I'm
using eval and sort of overall
performance of the system as the better
benchmark, right? So, eval are
important. We have to have those. Um I
you know the other side of the code like
you know Stride is a TDD shop like our
our our software engineers are very very
good at test-driven development and so
the blue box is very well tested. Um but
just my code you know very much is is
eval sort of tested instead. Um it's not
a great answer but like that that is
kind of how I thought about it.
All right. Um I think we are at time.
Thank you guys so much. This was
awesome. Um I'll be here if you want to
stick around.
[Music]